la séance est reprise nous reprenons la
discussion du projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 dans la suite de la
discussion nous sommes parvenus à la
parole de Monsieur Pierre Ouzoulias pour
l'article 7 vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cette
réforme a des conséquences budgétaires
importantes et le Président rotaïo nous
l'a dit avec force justesse alors
Monsieur le monsieur le ministre vous
devez la vérité aux Français aux
Français sur ce sujet vous devez nous
dire monsieur le ministre quel serait
les conséquences pour le budget de
l'état de votre réforme le président de
la République avait reconnu lui-même que
l'objet l'un des objets c'est très forme
était de trouver de nouvelles marges
budgétaires plusieurs économistes on
considérait que la hausse de recettes
pour l'État serait de 0,6 points de PIB
dans 10 ans
0,6 points de PIB dans 10 ans
je suis le ministre les Français et les
Françaises qui forment une nation très
politique ont compris l'objet de votre
projet et que votre projet pardon que
votre projet est d'instaurer un impôt un
nouvel impôt qui qui va leur coûter deux
années de leur vie
chers collègues de la majorité
sénatorial vous serez associé à ce
nouvel impôt sur la vie ils ont
manifesté en vase en masse aujourd'hui
pour vous dire qu'ils ne veulent pas de
ce nouvel impôt sur la vie payée par les
seuls salariés monsieur le ministre il
est temps maintenant de retirer votre
article merci monsieur le Président
Madame
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre votre obstination ne fait que
redoubler la colère des Français qui ont
été des millions aujourd'hui à dire
encore non à votre réforme des retraites
la mobilisation dans la rue est massive
déterminée obstiné la mobilisation des
esprits l'est aussi au-delà du recul de
l'âge à 64 ans c'est l'attitude du
président de la République et de son
gouvernement qui pose un véritable
problème les Français ne vous ont pas
élus pour cela mais vous agitez vous
agissez comme si c'était le cas nous
sommes désolés que le débat temp promis
aux Français n'est finalement pas eu
lieu combien d'amendements déposés par
l'opposition au Sénat ont-ils été adopté
quasiment aucun et cela restait ouvert
aux propositions du Sénat et trouver un
chemin ensemble comme le préconisé
madame borne monsieur
réforme de gauche sérieusement par cette
réforme vous dévoilez au contraire au
grand jour votre identité politique vous
êtes de droite dévoué au capital privé
et au modèle
ultra libéral si les vrais que
l'espérance de vie n'a cessé de
s'accroître pour les Français les
inégalités sociales face à la mort
demeure également à 65 ans pour cent des
plus pauvres sont déjà morts quand
seulement 7% des plus riches ces
chiffres sont effroyables un tiers des
Français les plus modestes passeront
leur vie entière à travailler et nous
trouverons un répit que dans la mort
c'est cela votre conception de la
justice sociale vous ne faites que
creuser davantage les inégalités de
toutes sortes sous couverts de
rééquilibrage du financement du système
de retraite retirer cette réforme le
peuple vous le demande faites-le avant
que la violence ne prenne le dessus dans
la rue et que les jeunes ne descendent
massivement dans cette même rue Monsieur
cadiction triste
comme vous le savez je représente les
Français établis hors de France au
Royaume-Uni où je réside l'âge légal de
la retraite c'est 66 ans ensuite c'est
65 ans en Belgique c'est aussi 65 ans ce
sera 66 en 2027 70 en 2030 en Allemagne
Italie c'est déjà 67 ans au Danemark 67
ans aussi mais ce sera 69 en 2035 il y a
tout juste un an lors de la campagne
présidentielle Emmanuel Macron avait
indiqué que l'âge de la retraite serait
porté à 65 ans afin de prendre en compte
les incompréhensions et dans une volonté
de recherche de consensus le
gouvernement a décidé de porter l'âge
légal de 62 à 64 ans et non plus à 65
ans c'est ce qui est prévu à l'article 7
la France aura toujours l'âge de départ
à la retraite le plus jeune beaucoup de
nos compatriotes à l'étranger sont
sidérés par les manifestations et les
protestations auxquelles nous assistons
pour la plupart d'entre eux ils sont
dans des pays où si on ne travaille pas
on ne mange pas à l'étranger la France
est vue comme le pays qui ont fait le
plus pour le social c'est un choix de
société me direz-vous
il n'a pas il n'apparaît pas pour autant
que les Français soient les plus heureux
du monde si j'en crois certains de nos
collègues depuis quatre jours dans cette
hémicycle au Sénat afin de consolider le
régime de retraite nous avons
régulièrement voté pour passer l'âge
légal à 65 ans le gouvernement a raison
d'aller dans cette direction il n'est
pas le seul à penser ainsi on vit plus
longtemps on travaille plus longtemps je
veux remercier les Français qui
comprennent que cet effort partagé est
nécessaire je vous remercie
Monsieur Daniel l'indépendant
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues si nous
voulons conserver l'équilibre des
comptes sociaux le régime des retraites
sans diminuer les pensions et augmenter
les cotisations conservées la sécurité
sociale ne pas reporter la dette sur les
futurs générations nous devons proposer
des solutions dans ce dans ce texte il y
en a deux l'augmentation plus vite que
prévu de 43 ans de cotisations
le report de l'âge les deux entraînant
un gain de 17 milliards d'euros la
première solution c'est la loi de 2014
du président Hollande la ministre
Touraine 43 ans de cotisation pour une
retraite complète 172 trimestres en 2035
le projet de loi la baisse de 7 ans en
2027 sans du tout changer la loi exemple
une personne est en 63 qui commence à
travailler à 21 ans en 24 84 pourra
partir avec la retraite avancée de
Madame Touraine en 2027 après 43 ans et
aura bien 64
concernant le report de l'âge de 62 à 74
certaines nous disent mais est-ce que la
loi Touraine ne suffirait pas de 40 pour
43 ans de cotisations c'est vrai que
dans ce cas plusieurs groupes ne
seraient pas concernés actifs hyperactif
fonctionnaires et d'autres personnes
monsieur le ministre pour les seniors le
gouvernement doit appliquer sans faute
sur ce qui est prévu dans ce projet de
loi est proposé par la Commission à
savoir la pénibilité c'est de paix
améliorer pour les carrières longues la
retraite à 1200 euros pour améliorer les
retraites des femmes pour les emplois
seniors doit être prioritaires comme le
préconise d'ailleurs la commission CDI
seniors retraite progressive aide aux
entreprises monsieur le ministre nous
voyons la mobilisation des syndicats je
pense qu'une loi de travail aurait été
utile avant ce projet en concertation
avec les partenaires sociaux il faut
trouver une solution pour renouer un
contact
utile merci
monsieur montogetaliste
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues monsieur le ministre nous
voilà donc à l'acné de ce terme de ce
texte régressif dont nos débats depuis
jeudi ont démontré qu'il est injuste in
justifié injustifiable et stigmatisant
pour certaines corporations un moment de
l'histoire de notre nation où l'on
attend du chef de l'État qui grâce à eux
qu'il ressoudent les composantes du
peuple français toutes appelées à faire
vivre les idéaux de la République a
contribué au bien commun dans un monde
ouvert et complexe voilà qu'on nous
présente comme l'alpha et l'oméga de la
politique de la France cette
prolongation de deux ans de vie au
travail alors pourquoi pourquoi ce
nouvel assujettissement de très nombreux
français parfois souvent
usé ou déjà cassé par une longue vie de
travail
et bien parce qu'il faut d'abord on ne
l'a pas dit assez de pigedi leur faire
payer l'amortissement des centaines de
milliards de quoi qu'il en coûte et
l'état calamiteux des contes publics qui
se sont dégradés considérablement depuis
2017 à l'heure de menaces mondiale
multiples dont certains observateurs
avisés nous disent qu'elles doivent être
prioritairement prise en compte pour
construire les politiques publiques de
demain je pense à la staculation au
climat aux inégalités à l'énergie aux
conséquences de l'intelligence
artificielle sur le travail etc
et au trop et au recomposition
géopolitique ou la France compte pour
trop peu et bien vous vous hystérisez
notre vie publique le travail est et
doit rester tout en évoluant dans le
cadre du dialogue social et de l'écoute
des corps intermédiaires un facteur
majeur de socialisation pour tous les
Français et de souveraineté nationale
dans l'équité et l'égalité homme-femme
vous êtes sourds à ces exigences dont la
prise en compte fera la place de la
France dans le monde et le bonheur des
Français qui ont droit au terme du vie
de labeur à 62 ans retirer cette réforme
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre tout d'abord je voudrais dire
quelques mots car je m'étonne voir je ne
comprends pas le silence de mes
collègues ceux de la majorité
présidentielle qui depuis jeudi ne sont
pas intervenus une seule fois pour
défendre votre réforme permettez-moi de
m'interroger cet article 7 contient la
mesure la plus dure de la réforme c'est
le cœur du réacteur de votre réforme le
report de 62 à 64 ans de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite en clair c'est plus
deux ans pour tout le monde aujourd'hui
les mobilisations massives pacifiques
qui ont lieu partout en France sur
l'expression d'un rejet des 64 ans par
l'immense majorité de la population et
du monde du travail mais ça vous ne
voulez pas le voir ni l'entendre et
c'est pour moi une faute démocratique
extrêmement grave vous savez que votre
réforme est injuste brutale que ceux qui
travaillent à temps partiel et notamment
les femmes les salariés précaires ou
ayant des emplois pénibles vos
particulièrement empathie on verra le
nombre de seniors
compris au chômage au RSA augmenté les
arrêts de maladies voir le risque
d'accident du travail vont croître dans
certains métiers si les gens travaillent
plus longtemps ça aussi vous le savez à
la veille du 8 mars la Journée
internationale des droits des femmes
l'égalité professionnelle devrait être
une exigence de justice sociale et un
vecteur de financement de notre système
de protection sociale cette exigence
demande de s'attaquer réellement aux
inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes ce que vous ne faites pas
vos approximations c'est peu de le dire
autour de la pension minimum à 1200
euros ne trompe plus plus de la moitié
des femmes partent avec une pension de
retraite inférieure à 1000 euros et ne
bénéficierons pas de la revolverisation
de 100 euros quant aux carrière longue
c'est à ne plus rien d'y comprendre vos
petites concessions à la droite des
mesurettes ne du personne vous aviez
promis d'aménager le dispositif
permettant à des parents anticiper en
retraite et là aussi les choses sont ne
sont absolument pas claires en vous
appuyant sur cet article 7 vous
prétendez faire une réforme budgétaire
permettant de sauver notre système de
retraite par répartition c'est faux
monsieur le Custer
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
Laurent Berger avait prévenu il y a déjà
de très nombreux mois
non à une réforme paramétrique
la même toise la même norme le même
chiffre pour tout le monde ce n'est pas
acceptable quand on connaît la diversité
des situations et cela a été dit redit
encore redit il y a tellement de métiers
difficiles pénibles dans beaucoup de
domaines on parle de la construction
mais on doit aussi parler du domaine
social moi j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer les aides à domicile et bien
lorsque vous devez aller dans cinq
foyers 5 maisons dans la journée avec
les temps de transport le soin aux
personnes le soin au domicile etc ce
sont des êtres humains qui sont très
fatigués et qui ne peuvent pas faire
cela jusqu'à 64 ans c'est évident donc
devant cette diversité des situations il
était possible de négocier autre chose
de prendre en compte la diversité mais
vous avez absolument voulu toute unifier
avec ses 64 ans et suscité cette colère
que l'on a vu encore aujourd'hui alors
par rapport à cela moi j'ai une seule
question à poser j'ai vu que les
organisations syndicales demandaient à
être reçu par le Président de la
République je dois dire que c'est la
moindre des choses et j'espère qu'enfin
ils auront une réponse et que il n'y
aura pas ce climat de diversion qui est
tout à fait incompréhensible et qui va
encore augmenter la colère et le
désarroi
madame espagnol
merci monsieur le président
malgré l'opposition de l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales malgré
l'opposition depuis de huit Français sur
10 malgré les millions de grévistes qui
ont marqué marcher dans tout le pays
vous vous obstinez à mener cette réforme
injuste et à vouloir décaler à 64 ans
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
pourtant une autre réforme était
possible lorsque nous avons fait la
réforme Touraine en 2014 nous avons
étalé dans le temps l'effort de mandé
sur 20 ans jusqu'en 2035 et surtout nous
avons réparti l'effort entre les
retraités les employeurs et les salariés
l'urgence est de mettre plus de justice
dans notre système de retraite le
décalage à 64 ans va toucher ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler le plus tôt et
les plus précaires cela va augmenter le
nombre de personnes ni en emploi ni en
retraite et ils sont déjà 1,5 millions
l'adresse a chiffré après ce 4 milliards
l'impact des réformes sur les
prestations annexes invalidité minima
sociaux c'est un jeu de bon taux que
vous mettez en place des gens devront
encore travailler 44 ans soit un an de
plus que les 43 taille unités requises
c'est une double peine la véritable
nécessité et de résoudre les inégalités
face à l'espérance de vie il y a
aujourd'hui 13 ans d'écart entre
l'espérance de vie des 5% des Français
les plus riches dans notre pays et des 5
français les plus pauvres la véritable
nécessité et aussi de résoudre les
inégalités de pension entre les femmes
et les hommes
alors il aurait fallu augmenter le taux
d'emploi des plus de 55 ans grâce à la
formation continue à un dispositif
spécialisé dans compagnement au retour à
l'emploi à la retraite progressive et le
régime aurait été ainsi équilibré à
l'horizon 20232 il aurait fallu revenir
sur les exonérations de cotisation pour
les salariés supérieures à 2,5
milliards d'euros par an le corps dans
son scénario le plus pessimiste dit
qu'il suffisait de en 2028 d'augmenter
les cotisations de 14 euros au niveau du
SMIC et de 28 au niveau des salaires
médian pour assurer l'équilibre du
système des retraites enfin il aurait
fallu récupérer tout ou partie de la CSG
affectée à la cadèse en allongeant le
rythme remboursement au-delà de 2033 ou
en sortant la dette covid afin de
récupérer les 9 milliards d'euros par an
choisissez donc la voie du progrès
social et non la régression sociale
entendez le message des Français qui ont
manifesté aujourd'hui dans les rues de
France retirer cette réforme merci
monsieur Lecomte
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues monsieur
les ministres mes chers collègues de la
majorité sénatoriale si vous votez cet
article vous vous attaquerez à la
capacité de la nation d'avoir confiance
dans son avenir vous vous attaquerez à
la justice sociale et vous vous
attaquerez à la République vous vous
attaquerez à la capacité de la nation
d'avoir confiance dans son avenir car
cela fait maintenant plus de 30 ans
qu'on explique aux Français que leur
retraite ne sont pas finançables et à
chaque fois on fait une réforme avec les
mêmes solutions des solutions qui ne
marchent pas alors que nous vous disons
qu'aujourd'hui le système est finançable
que le la pourcentage de de
des pensions dans le PIB reste constant
et à la même vocation abaisser ce qui
pourrait d'ailleurs être inquiétant sur
le montant des pensions vous vous
attaquez à la justice sociale car ce
sont les plus fragiles qui demain un
paieront vedette qui partiront plus tard
avec des pensions plus faibles et qui
vivront dans une précarité parfois
terrible et enfin Monsieur les ministres
vous vous attaquez à la public monsieur
les ministres si vous êtes sur ces bancs
aujourd'hui c'est parce que la gauche a
considéré qu'Emmanuel Macron devait être
élu pour éviter Madame Le Pen le
populisme le nationalisme la remise en
cause de l'état de droit et le repli sur
soi ne trahi pas ce manque d'âme c'est
le ministre c'est ce que le peuple vous
a dit 4 millions de Français aujourd'hui
dans les rues il vous demande de ne pas
trahir ce mandat ce mandat qui vous
demande de défendre la République et
vous l'attaquez vive la République vive
la retraite à 62 ans
Monsieur Alain billon
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
tout d'abord faire une remarque à Madame
Marie madame marie-sol
vous avez dit que nous n'avions pas
auditionné les syndicats c'est faux vous
savez très bien que la Commission
d'affaires sociales a au dossier
l'ensemble des syndicats de salariés et
que tout le monde était présent les
représentants de la gauche et les
représentants de la droite par contre
dans la foulée nous avons auditionné
aussi les syndicats patronaux et là la
droite était présente mais la gauche
vous êtes parti seul Raymonde seul
Raymond est resté dire que ça par contre
la tolérance veut qu'on écoute tout le
monde c'est le premier point deuxième
point je me suis souvenu d'une phrase de
Spinoza qui disait ni rire ni rire ni
pleurer ni détester mais comprendre
j'essaye de comprendre la loi du 20
janvier 2014 qui garantit l'avenir et la
justice du système de retraite cette loi
a été déposée à l'Assemblée nationale le
2 octobre 2013 au Sénat le 15 octobre
2013 a rapporteur était notre collègue
Christiane de Montech nous avons eu pour
étudier cette loi cette jour puisque on
l'a étudié le 28 29 30 31 le 4 et le 2
novembre entre couloir donc coincé entre
le Pell et FSS et le PLF cette loi met
en place 43 ennuités pour l'ensemble
l'âge moyen d'entrer dans le travail en
France c'est 22 ans et 7 mois c'est à
dire que donc les gens qui rentrent dans
le travail à 22 ans et 7 mois à 62 ans
n'ont pas l'intégralité de leur
trimestre et quand ils prennent leur
retraite ils ont une proratisation par
rapport au nombre de trimestres qu'ils
ont cotisés et une des cotes
c'est-à-dire que vous faites en fait des
retraités pauvres cela dit donc nous 64
ans c'est pas l'âge idéal pour les 43
ans de la loi de Touraine ce savait
plutôt du plutôt être 45 ans
c'est-à-dire donc les propositions
faites pas la commission d'affaires
sociales à travers René Paul sur la
pénibilité sur les femmes sur
l'accessibilité sur le handicap sur la
validité ce sont des mesures qui
cherchent à adoucir les rigueurs de la
loi Touraine
madame la Présidente rossignol
[Applaudissements]
pour
la Commission a reçu les syndicats
encore le 16 février j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure de recevoir l'Inter syndical et
tous ceux qui ont un peu d'expérience
des mouvements sociaux savent qu'une
interditale ce n'est pas la même chose
que la somme des syndicats reçus un par
un les uns à côté des autres et
d'ailleurs la revendication de
l'intersynamical c'est aussi par le
gouvernement c'était interpellé
bien madame Poumirol que voilà
merci monsieur le Président nous vivons
plus longtemps nous devons travailler
plus longtemps tel est la litanie que
vous n'aurez prêté depuis le début de ce
débat c'est la seule logique qui semble
animer votre projet alors qu'en fait
vous faites une réforme budgétaire pour
combler les déficit liés aux cadeaux que
vous avez fait au riche pourtant la
recette la réalité démocratie est loin
d'être aussi simple et la réponse ne
devrait pas être au système piste en
effet il faut différencier l'espérance
de vie de l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé qui varie selon la classe sociale
d'origine et l'emploi occupé parce que
ce qui est important c'est la qualité de
vie à la retraite alors les chiffres
sont là 5% des hommes les plus riches
ont une espérance de vie de 84 ans
contre 71,7 pour les 5% les plus pauvres
soit un écart de 13 ans dans le
gouvernement ne semble pas prendre la
mesure pour les femmes l'écart est de
8,3 ans aujourd'hui en France les plus
pauvres passent sept années de moins à
la que les plus aisés avec votre réforme
ils perdront encore deux ans c'est un
impôt sur la vie inacceptable alors non
la justification démographique n'est pas
réelle elle est dogmatique notre système
de retraite a un problème de recettes
nous n'avons juste de cesse de vous le
répéter et de vous faire des
propositions que vous avez aveuglément
refusé nous répondons donc cette réformé
inutile et injuste nous ne voulons pas
de cette impôt sur la vie qui pénalisera
essentiellement les plus défavorisés
ayant des métiers les plus pénibles
retirer cette réforme madame la
Présidente Laurence Rossignol
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président je crois
qu'on est rentré aujourd'hui dans une
nouvelle phase du mouvement social et de
la confrontation autour de cette réforme
des retraites jusqu'à présent nous
avions un sujet social la réforme des
retraites à partir d'aujourd'hui nous
avons désormais un sujet démocratique il
y avait 1,12 millions de personnes je
prends les chiffres du ministère de
l'Intérieur à la première manifestation
toujours chiffre de l’intérieur 1,28
aujourd'hui vous avez eu beau menacé le
pays des dix plaies d'Égypte vous avez
eu beau parier sur le fait que les
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat des
Français et les empêcher de se mettre en
grève et pour autant ils ont été encore
plus nombreux aujourd'hui qui est
maintenant la question monsieur le
ministre c'est qu'allez-vous faire parce
que au-delà des votes qui auront lieu
dans cette assemblée qu'allez-vous faire
du mouvement social c'est ça le sujet
sur quoi jouez-vous le pourrissement la
gilets jaunisation le fait qu'à un
moment donné des gens soient tellement
désespérés qu'il préfère alors qu'ils
avaient un mouvement démocratique et
sympathique au départ
s'exprimer par la violence à force de ne
pas être entendue
c'est quoi votre pari c'est celui de
l'épuisement voyez-vous monsieur le
ministre votre réforme va coûter deux
ans de vie aux Français
elle risque de coûter des années à la
démocratie au facteurs républicain des
années c'est ça que nous essayons
aujourd'hui de vous faire comprendre
c'est que nos divergences ici sur
l'allongement de largeur retraite on est
connaît mais jamais ils se sont déroulés
dans un débat où il y avait un million
et demi à 3 millions de personnes dans
la rue jamais les Français ne se sont
autant impliqués dans ce débat et
aujourd'hui la balle dans votre camp où
est passé le discours du président de la
République du deuxième tour de la
présidentielle où est-il le discours de
cet homme qui nous disent nous remercier
qui remercient ces gens qui sont joués
dans la rue d'avoir voté pour lui alors
que le Front National et l'extrême
droite sont en embuscade que la
radicalité menace de tous les côtés
qu'allez-vous faire de notre pays
monsieur le ministre c'est ça le sujet
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres
j'ai lu l'interview du ministre ce
week-end qui disait être un homme de
gauche et une réforme de gauche
sauf que quand je regarde cette réforme
là proposer est-ce qu'elle est en train
de devenir au Sénat je crois que vous
êtes maintenant dans l'erreur et tout le
monde est prêt je crois que Monsieur mix
que 20 ans vous êtes en train d'être
dévoré par la droite finalement et moi
je comprends mes collègues les collègues
de droite qui ne prennent très peu la
parole
la droite on a rêvé
même sous Sarkozy même sush Chirac elle
n'a pas pu le faire ou n'a pas su le
faire on n'a pas voulu le faire et vous
le referez cela sur un plateau mais la
réalité elle est simple c'est parce qu'à
la fois vous avez effectivement avec le
beaucoup des entreprises maintenant il
faut financer c'est l'addition payer par
tous les Français
et de l'autre côté vous n'avez plus de
majorité pour tenir dans ce pays
et d'ailleurs on le voit bien ce qui va
se passer dans la séance après la
capitalisation après le contrat pour les
seniors il y aura d'autres mesures qui
vont détricoter le lien social et le
pacte social dans les prochains heures
dans les prochains jours et comme vous
aurez le vous aurez l'obligation d'avoir
la droite avec vous pour le faire passer
à l'Assemblée vous céderez donc
finalement monsieur le ministre vous
aurez été l'homme de gauche qui aura
fait la victoire la plus absolue contre
le mot social contre les Français avec
votre réforme de retrait donc encore une
fois il y a le débat il y a le débat il
se préoccupe de gauche j'accepte qu'il
soit de gauche c'est son propos
j'accepte son propos encore une fois
monsieur le ministre il y a la
démocratie parlementaire que nous
connaissons et que nous appliquons ici
au Sénat mais la démocratie sociale
existe également les syndicats
participent également à la vie sociale
de notre pays c'est inscrit dans la
Constitution française alors moi je vous
demande une chose
d'abord que vous puissiez faire l'écho
des Français dans la rue faire les cours
de l'Inter syndicale et encore une fois
si vous avez un rôle à tenir dans les
prochaines heures c'est de proposer au
président de recevoir la terre syndicale
parce que je crois que là le pays
pouvoir redescendre en termes de
pression et nous pourrons continuer les
travaux et faire une réforme juste et
donc pas cette réforme là
Monsieur Thomas dessus
merci monsieur le Président on arrive
effectivement ce soir
au débat sur l'article 7 au soir d'une
journée historique l'une des plus
grandes mobilisations sociales depuis 50
ans dans toutes les territoires dans
toutes les villes quel que soit leur
taille les Français vous ont hurlé
rejettent cette réforme oui nous sommes
dans une situation de blocage
démocratique et pourtant il y a quelques
mois ici ici la première ministre
Élisabeth borne était venu nous dire son
discours de politique générale et elle
nous avait dit en 30 ceci nous
consulterons plus encore les corps
intermédiaires les forces vives de notre
pays les Françaises et les Français de
chaque territoire plus que jamais nous
mènerons chaque réforme en lien étroit
avec les organisations syndicales six
mois plus tard elle présentait ce projet
de loi
avec son mépris elle a créé une interte
syndicale historique qui a construit un
mouvement social exemplaire massif
déterminé et pacifique pour l'instant
parce que les seuls alliés qu'elle a
trouvé ils étaient ici dans cette auto
assemblée c'est le groupe LR fidèle à
ses idéaux réactionnaires qui a servi de
buen sauvetage au gouvernement
complice du tour de force démocratique
mais la majorité sénatoriale depuis 4
jours a choisi en grande partie le
silence moi je vois des collègues ici
ils ont passé 4 jours dans un fauteuil à
lever la main en suivant les consignes
de vote du gouvernement pourtant vous le
devez au français expliquez expliquez
pourquoi pourquoi les Français vont
devoir trimer deux ans de plus expliquer
l'heure pourquoi vous avez toujours
voulu épargner les plus favorisés et
parmi les super profiteurs de crise et
parmi la rente épargner le capital
depuis trois jours alors ici dans la
chambre des territoires on va vous
demander une chose entendez les millions
de voix qui sont élevés dans toutes les
villes dans tous les villages dans tous
vos territoires et renoncer à cette
réforme brutale et tellement injuste
madame gréaume
merci
votre gouvernement vient de briser le
plafond de verre vous avez oublié que
vous n'avez pas été élu en majorité pour
votre programme vous avez oublié que
vous avez bénéficié en partie du report
républicain ce n'est pas la même chose
et malgré tout vous n'écoutez pas le
peuple qui crie haut et fort qui ne
veulent pas de cette réforme et vous la
majorité sénatoriale expliquée aux
salariés pourquoi vous n'avez pas voulu
voter les différentes propositions de
financement que l'on vous a proposé elle
est belle la démocratie même le
référendum a été refusé la seule
solution pour vous c'est de reculer
l'âge du départ à la retraite pour vous
des efforts doivent être faits mais
dites moi pourquoi des efforts
viendraient uniquement des salariés
pourquoi ne pas associer le grand
patronat ou les plus aisés c'est comme
cela que vous remercier ceux qui
produisent en France et ceux qui font
tourner l'économie du pays
selon le journal Le Monde des enquêtes
réalité
réalisées par la direction ministérielle
et ont été présentés lors d'une réunion
du Conseil d'orientation des retraites
en janvier 2022 ces enquêtes confirment
que cette réforme va interdits dommages
collatéraux ce décalage d'âge de 62 à 64
ans va se traduire par une hausse 94000
bénéficiaires d'allocations chômage donc
60000 euros entre 62 et 63 ans en plus
il y aura une bascule vers les minimax
sociaux 30000 au RSA 30 000 en
allocation solidarité spécifique deux
fois droit voilà la réforme que vous
proposez celle qui va appauvrir la
France alors Monsieur le Ministre
retirez cette réforme quoi croyez-moi le
conflit social va se durcir
monsieur le Président rénal
avec cet article 7 faisant passer l'âge
légal de retraite de 62 à 64 ans nous en
venons finalement au seul point qui est
unit la droite macroniste à la droite
sénatoriale
pourquoi d'ailleurs en sommes-nous là
uniquement parce que cette mesure qui a
été vous l'avez souvent dit présenté à
quatre reprises dans les PLFSS
précédents était la condition finalement
de l'accord et la seule condition de la
corde depuis vendredi vous nous amusez
tous avec un index senior
inutile et non contraignant vous nous
amusez avec un contrat senior
inutile et qui serait un véritable effet
domaine pour les entreprises vous nous
amusez en présentant un tableau
d'équilibre de la réforme pour le moins
peu crédible
depuis vendredi
vous ouvrez la voie en fait à la réforme
qui vient
alors certains ont dit une espèce de
retour au système à point pour les uns
une introduction d'une capitalisation
collective pour les autres et d'ailleurs
on commence déjà à entendre la petite
musique je suis sûr que vous l'entendez
comme moi d'un équilibre financier à
l'issue des travaux parlementaires en
2030 il serait donc cet équilibre
financier qui devait être à 17 milliards
je vous le rappelle de gains incertain
maintenant bref on commence à nous
susurrer que cette réforme serait
inutile d'où l'idée de commencer à
travailler sur la suite et puis je vais
vous dire une chose chers collègues
chers collègues LR essayez maintenant de
ne plus déposer d'amendement sur les
retraites merci
Monsieur Patrice Joly
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues je voudrais
souligner les inégalités territoriales
supplémentaires
que va générer ce projet de loi et ce
report de l'âge de la retraite de deux
ans en effet les territoires ruraux
présentent des caractères particuliers
sur les métiers exercés métiers
particulièrement pénible et donc qui use
ceux qui les pratiques le poids de
certains secteurs est nettement plus
élevé que la moyenne nationale sur ces
territoires je fais référence à
l'agriculture à la civiculture à la
transformation du bois au bâtiment aux
travaux publics aux métiers de
l'industrie notamment métallurgique car
et oui les territoires ruraux sont des
territoires d'industrie historiquement
et présentement mais je pense également
aux métiers de service à la personne
aide ménagère aide-soignante infirmiers
liés à la part des personnes âgées au
sein des populations de ces territoires
les écarts d'espérance de vie entre les
territoires sont déjà importants deux
ans en moyenne au détribuant des
territoires ruraux et jusqu'à 4 ans dans
certains cas en particulier dans le
département que je représente les
raisons sont multiples niveau de revenus
accès difficile aux professionnels de
santé aux établissements de soins nous
sommes d'ailleurs payés en ce moment
pour le savoir avec la fermeture de
inacceptables en ce moment de la
maternité d'Autun fermeture contestée
par les élus et la population à cause
des risques qu'elle générait pour les
maires et pour les nourrissons des
écarts liés bien sûr aux métiers tels
que je viens de les évoquer et à leur
pénibilité si nous n'y ajoute les écarts
selon les catégories sociales jusqu'à
présent comme nous l'a rappelé à
l'instant notre collègue Emilienne peu
Mirol on mesure alors les inégalités
existantes déjà et pour lesquelles
aucune politique suffisante n'étant
n'est mise en œuvre pour les réduire
alors Monsieur le Ministre n'ajoutez pas
de l'injustice à l'injustice et retirer
ce à la fois cet article et ce projet de
loi je vous remercie madame Préville
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous les
femmes allons subir une régression de
nos droits sans précédent à cause de
votre réforme des retraites nous droit
nous les avons acquis difficilement nous
nous voyons pas à vrai dire le bout du
chemin vers l'égalité ce qui est
légitime
et c'est d'ailleurs à se demander
combien de milliers d'années il nous
faudra pour aboutir enfin à l'égalité
salariale et combien de temps il nous
faudra quémander justice c'est bien
d'une tristesse absolue et en plus le
peu que nous avions vous l'enlevez les
trimestres légitimement pour les enfants
vous les supprimer sans vraiment le dire
et c'est parce que vos incantations à la
pédagogie sous prétexte de mieux faire
comprendre votre projet qu'enfin le
lièvre a été levé maintenant nous le
savons les femmes sont perdantes elles
sont les grandes perdantes de votre
projet de loi et c'est scandaleux
comment
osez-vous comment avez-vous
osé laissez croire le contraire preuve
de l'injustice faite aux femmes je vous
en donne une une femme dans le privé né
après 1967 début de carrière à 21 ans un
enfant sans réforme elle peut partir à
62 ans à taux plein
et elle peut bénéficier même d'une
surcote de 10% si elle va jusqu'à 64 ans
avec la réforme pas de départ à 62 ans
un départ obligatoire à 64 ans et elle
n'aura qu'une surcote de 5%. voilà la
preuve est faite la réalité la voix là
je vous donne également la parole d'une
manifestante dans mon département aesh
dans un collège qui devra travailler
jusqu'à 67 ans pour avoir 500 euros de
retraite on a dit et je la cite on a des
trous dans nos carrières on a des
métiers précaires et mal payés et notre
statut n'est pas reconnu elle était dans
la rue aujourd'hui comme plus de 3
millions de Français le mauvais coup que
vous faites aux femmes ne m'inspire
qu'une seule chose impardonnable
je
merci monsieur le président
je crois que nous avons tout ce que nous
ici un certain nombre de chefs de l'État
et des chefs de l'État qui confrontaient
à des mouvements d'opinion parfois bien
moins importants que celui qui a lieu en
ce moment on s'y prend la bonne décision
c'est-à-dire retirer un projet je pense
à François Mitterrand en 1984 et ça ne
me faisait pas plaisir
et il est resté 11 ans à l'Élysée
derrière sa vie politique ne s'est pas
arrêtée et n'a pas été condamné à
l'inaction je pense à Jacques Chirac
aussi et il n'a pas plus été condamné à
l'inaction il y a une sagesse à écouter
le peuple et je dois dire que à ceux qui
prétendent que ce n'est pas la rue qui
gouverne ce n'est pas la rue qui fait la
loi c'est slogans éculé je réponds que
la démocratie parlementaire elle ne
s'affaiblit pas quand elle écoute le
peuple elle se renforce et elle se
renforce parce qu'elle montre qu'elle a
un lien direct avec le peuple qu'elle
écoute et si elle n'écoute pas si elle
ne répond pas à ce dialogue à ce lien et
bien ce sont les extrêmes qui en
profitent derrière et ce qui est en
train de se passer dans notre pays
m'inquiète je comprends que vous soyez
attaché à cette réforme vous l'avez
toujours porté je sais les valeurs
qu'elles réelles pour vous dans la
majorité sénatoriale je sais les
messages que vous voulez porter
politiquement
mais interrogez-vous vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui le lien que vous avez que
nous avons enfin vous en l'occurrence là
et menacé parce que c'est dans les
petites villes parce que c'est dans
toute la France que le mouvement est
puissant que ce soit la rue ou les
enquêtes d'opinion vous le voyez alors
je crois qu'il est il est temps de faire
prévaloir des intérêts qui dépassent ce
simple texte
renoncer ce n'est pas une honte
reprendre remettre l'ouvrage sur le
métier dans de meilleures conditions
c'est la garantie que la société entière
l'accepte il faut cesser digne viser
notre pays il est assez fragile il faut
le rassembler et retirer ce texte
[Applaudissements]
le ministre mes chers collègues malgré
l'opposition historique qui a eu lieu ce
mardi 7 mars malgré l'opposition de
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
malgré l'opposition de plus de 8
Français sur dix vous vous obstinez à
vouloir aller au bout de cette réforme
injuste
cet article 7 par le rayonnement de
l'âge légal de la retraite et
l'accélération de la hausse de durée de
cotisation impose une double peine pour
ceux ayant commencé à travailler tôt où
il y a eu des carrières hachées ou
pénibles cet article 7 concentre le cœur
des injustices de cette loi c'est une
mesure brutale et disproportionnée par
rapport aux prévisions de déficit du
système de retraite ce report de l'âge
légal nous est présenté comme un horizon
indépassable alors qu'il résute il
résulte bien d'un choix idéologique
promu par la droite malgré cette
opposition d'une majorité de nos
concitoyens la vraie la réalité la
vérité c'est que le système de retraite
n'est pas structurellement en danger il
n'y a pas de menace de déficit
insurmontable
le corps lui-même juge dans son rapport
qu'il n'y a pas de dynamique non
contrôlée des dépenses de retraite il
parle de territoire maîtrisés jusqu'en
2070 mais sans doute voyez-vous plus
loin vous qui n'avez pas vu venir le
réchauffement climatique vous souhaitez
réquilibrer financièrement un système de
retraite que vous estimez à la dérive et
bien nous vous avons donné de nombreuses
pistes taxés davantage les pensions de
retraite les plus élevées augmenter le
taux d'emploi des seniors et donner à
chacun une garantie d'emploi dans des
métiers utiles à la société mais
n'imposait pas cette réforme contre la
vie de toutes les organisations
syndicales contre la grande majorité des
Françaises et des Français si vous
choisissez de poursuivre dans cette voie
vous causeriez un tort considérable à
notre pays retirer cette réforme tant
qu'il en est encore temps merci
la roche
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Aya de Dream j'ai eu un rêve
celui du vrai loi travail une loi du 21e
siècle une oie qui tienne côte des
énormes modifications de l'organisation
du travail que vivent nos sociétés une
loi qui fasse ruisseler les gains de
productivité de mécanisation de la
robotisation sur les travailleurs et les
travailleurs et pas uniquement pour
aborder les profits des grands capitaux
celui d'un gouvernement monsieur le
ministre qui gouverne c'est-à-dire qu'il
prévoit qui co-élaborent avec les
citoyens avec les travailleurs avec les
parlementaires avec les syndicats au
lieu de cela cette loi de calcul
comptable de faits de siècles et bâti
sur des présupposés qui ne sont plus
réalisés aujourd'hui dans nos sociétés
industrielles au lieu de cela le
gouvernement s'apprête mais dans la main
avec la majorité de droite et centrices
du Sénat à porter atteinte au droit à la
retraite de millions de nos concitoyens
et à notre système de retraite par
répartition
un projet de loi qui contrairement aux
annonces de l'exécutif ne permettra pas
d'équilibrer financièrement le système
vous commencez à le dire de préserver le
système par répartition on a vu les
amendements sur le système de
capitalisation ni de garantir une traite
minimum de 1200 euros par mois ça vous
avez dû laver on repoussant de deux ans
la d'ouverture des droits à la retraite
le but de cet article n'est ni plus ni
moins que de faire peser l'équilibre du
système de retraite sur le dos des
travailleurs et des travailleurs plutôt
que sur le capital ne parvenant pas à
défendre son projet le Gouvernement a
souhaité museler et tronquer le débat
par le recours à un texte de financement
avec le PLF RSS
sur le président monsieur le ministre ce
soir tous ensemble sur ces bancs nous
sommes les voies les interprètes de
toutes ces voix qui se sont réunies
nombreux par centaines de milliers par
millions cet après-midi alors au moins
cette réforme aura eu un avantage de
révéler un bloc de gauche et un seul
bloc de droite dans cette assemblée
pourtant rien ne va dans cette réforme
on l'a dit et on vous le répète sans
cesse la procédure fixée un critère une
décision unilatérale du montant à
rembourser prendre le critère le plus
injuste celui des 64 ans avec des études
d'impact lacunaire avec une absence de
prise en compte des conséquences sur le
chômage sur les seniors et puis des
vérités alternatives comme celle des
1200 euros les Français ne veulent pas
de cette réforme et ils voulont dit haut
et fort une réforme à justifiée parce
que ce n'est pas une question de déficit
c'est une question de manque de recettes
et puis
on vous l'a dit et vous le redis
monsieur le ministre une réforme qui
fait des perdants les femmes les plus
faibles les carrières hachées
et
j'en viens à Monsieur le Ministre
à vous poser une question vous êtes
comme moi comme d'autres dans cette
hémicycle ce qu'on appelle un
transfuge de un transfuge de classe vous
avez eu une trajectoire tout à fait
particulière et pourtant vous avez des
origines modestes vous avez été comme
moi je crois boursier qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé monsieur le ministre à quel
moment avez-vous oublié d'où vous venez
comment Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous
brutaliser ce que vous avez connu et qui
vous regarde monsieur le ministre que
vous est-il arrivé réveillez-vous
réveillez-vous monsieur le ministre et
souvenez-vous de celui que vous avez été
madame louer au
merci monsieur le Président il y a d'un
côté les coûts cachés qui limitent
l'intérêt de reporter l'âge à 64 ans le
surcoût du report à 64 ans atteignait 8
milliards d'euros de coûts liés à
l'invalidité c'est le président national
de la Mutualité Française qui donne ce
chiffre c'est un risque supplémentaire
d'ouvrir et de renforcer la trappe à
pauvreté pour les seniors qui sont ni en
emploi ni à la retraite mais il n'est
absolument pas démontré que le seniors
coûterait globalement moins cher à la
société en restant plus longtemps sur le
marché du travail les jeunes retraités
de ma région Bretagne me témoignent de
leur rôle essentiel et leur
investissement dans des associations
caritatives culturelles sportives ou
dans la vie municipale nombreux sont
ceux qui se lèvent à 6h du matin pour
préparer les colis des Restos du coeur
ou pour récupérer le pain invendu dans
les boulangeries
c'est Français préfèrent prendre leur
retraite certains Français préfèrent
prendre leur retraite et travailler
bénévolement pour une cause à laquelle
il croit et dont il mesure concrètement
l'intérêt plutôt que de continuer à
travailler ils sont là où le service
public a défaillance auprès des jeunes
pour l'accompagnement aux devoirs auprès
des familles pauvres des étrangers
délaissés de nos aînés isolées ils
interviennent dans les EHPAD pour
soutenir le personnel qui n'en peut plus
vous n'avez pas tenu compte de ces coûts
cachés avez-vous évalué la richesse
cachée qui est produite par ces jeunes
retraités qui sont inquiets du report
obligatoire de l'âge de la retraite avec
cette proposition de loi sur les
retraites ne risque-t-on pas de voir
s'écrouler tout un pan économique de la
société qui n'est pas analysé et qui
constitue des richesses cachées ces
retraites ces retraités s'inquiètent de
votre réforme ils étaient dans la rue
aujourd'hui pour défendre les droits de
leurs enfants ils vous demandent le
retrait de l'article 7 de la loi il veut
il vous demande le retrait de la loi
monsieur Mériot
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames et messieurs et chers
collègues
le report de deux ans de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite constitue une
mesure antisociale et une grande
injustice en frappant aveuglément avec
une brutalité inouïe toutes celles et
tous ceux qui ont travaillé toute leur
vie toutes celles et tous ceux qui se
sont levés tôt vous attaquez l'idée même
du progrès et de la justice sociale
vous imposer à toutes et à tous un impôt
sur la vie en bonne santé un impôt de
deux ans sur ce temps libre qui échoua
chacune et à chacun après une vie de
labeur
au nom d'un pseudo pseudo pragmatisme
gestionnaire qui ne saurait dissimulé
une certaine soumission à la cupidité
des actionnaires vous sacrifiez lui-même
pour rassurer les marchés en imposant
votre dogme libéral vos arguments sur le
ministre sont fallacieux le corps la
démontré les études et les contre
projets latesses et pourtant vous vous
arcboutez à une mesure profondément
juste et antisociale au nom d'une
urgence imaginaire qui menacerait le
système par répartition et ce n'est pas
faute d'avoir été sur nos bancs force de
proposition pour imaginer ensemble notre
avenir malgré beaucoup de mentons malgré
votre tsunami de communication vous qui
est occupez jusqu'à ne plus finir les
plateaux de télé des millions de
Français vous disent non ils ne sont pas
dupe vous baptisés progrès des reculs
sociaux vous appelez réforme juste un
impôt sur la vie à force de fascination
pour les cabinets de conseils vous avez
perdu je le crains le sens du réel vous
ne mesurez plus le coût humain de vos
arbitrages vous n'avez pas parmi vos
statistiques celui de la désespérance
celui de la colère de ceux qui par de la
colère de ceux qui ne se sentent plus
entendu
je me suis Assouline
je crois que pour comprendre ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui et ce qui est
incompréhensible dans cette émission il
faut qu'ensemble on essaye de
retourner un peu en arrière dans cette
émission un moment de tétanisation dans
le pays
qui a été la crise du covid
on n'avait jamais vu ça
et
on a vu un pays qui a tenu à travers ses
premiers corvées c'était les infirmières
c'était les aides-soignants c'était les
salariés de la grande distribution
c'était tous ceux qui continuaient à
faire tourner le pays
et on s'est dit à ce moment-là
dans cet tétanisation qu'il y avait
peut-être un moment de grâce car de
droite ou de gauche tout le monde
regardez
ces gens là
avec une admiration et une
reconnaissance inouïe et nous les
applaudissions et on se disait ça pourra
pas être comme avant après ça
souvenez-vous
les salaires
derrière l'inflation aujourd'hui les
angoisses de la crise climatique
et puis pour eux c'est comme avant
empire
c'est-à-dire qu'on vient leur dire merci
on leur autant à eux
ceux qui font les métiers les plus
pénibles et qui se lèvent tôt le matin
et qui ont tenu le pays à ce moment-là
qu'on va leur prendre les deux meilleurs
années de leur retraite
et que s'ils veulent travailler plus
alors je le dis très franchement pour
mesurer l'ampleur du mouvement social
qui s'est exprimée dans la rue prenez en
compte tout ça et vous venez ajouter la
goutte d'eau qui peut faire déborder le
vase et ce mouvement ne va pas s'arrêter
là parce qu'il est profond oui mais il y
a un seul président oui mais il fait
respecter le temps s'il vous plaît
monsieur fichier monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues
il y a gêne de ce côté-ci de l'hémicycle
il y a gêne et elle est palpable à
travers votre mutisme il y a plusieurs
formes au silence j'en retiens 3 le
premier c'est je me tais parce que je
n'ai rien à dire le deuxième c'est je me
tais parce que je ne crois pas à ce que
je vais dire le troisième c'est je me
tais parce que je pourrais donner raison
à mes contradicteurs
même sur les réseaux sociaux le projet
qui est censé apaiser les gens et leur
faire rêver à une retraite agréable ne
marche pas alors service minimum et les
commentaires à ceux qui se risquent ce
les réseaux sociaux sont impitoyables
tout cela
s'illustre par une prise de position
d'une parlementaire de votre majorité ou
plutôt de la majorité de renaissance
dans mon département
elle dit en première page d'un grand
quotidien je vote parce que je ne peux
pas faire autrement
tout est dit
il vous reste à évaluer en quoi vous
allez améliorer l'avenir des Français à
travers votre projet de loi
et comme on n'a pas beaucoup de moyens
d'évaluer dans un temps immédiat on va
retenir les sénatoriales
les mers qui sont très proches de leur
population qui les entendent
régulièrement sont sensibles à leur
difficulté et à l'inertie de cette loi
et je pense très clairement qu'il vous
le diront très prochainement à tous les
candidats des sénatoriales de la droite
qu'il aura imposé un système de retraite
qui leur fait travailler deux années de
plus je vous remercie pour conclure
Madame Lubin
merci monsieur le président
la donne est simple le cadre budgétaire
européen impose aux États membres une
pression permanente pour réduire leur
déficits publics et leurs dettes les
retraites représentent une cible
privilégiée puisqu'elles sont un poste
important de la dépense publique donc
vous avez choisi de taper les retraites
et comme vous voulez faire des économies
immédiates vous devez organiser un
moindre versement de pension et des
rentrées de cotisations plus importantes
donc empêcher les Français qui doivent
faire valoir leur droit à la retraite
dans les deux ans qui viennent
de le faire
ceux qui travaillent déjà depuis plus de
cas depuis plus de 40 ans
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler jeune
donc
et qui exerce souvent les métiers les
plus difficiles
ces Français ont parfaitement compris
mais vous vous ne comprenez pas
les millions de Français descendent dans
la rue font grève se prive de salaire
et le président de la République regarde
d'ailleurs
le porte-parole du gouvernement a
annoncé la fin du monde si les Français
persistaient à manifester leur colère
déclaration ridicule s'il en était
mais ce ne sont pas ces Français là qui
menacent d'autres pays
c'est l'entêtement de votre gouvernement
son mépris qui blesse les Français et il
n'y a rien de bon à attendre d'un peuple
blessé
et en tout état de cause je sais une
chose c'est que les ministres aux bandes
ne m'ont pas entendu pas plus que ses
amis que les éminents représentant de
cette majorité dans le Sénat parce qu'il
se moque du tiers comme du quart de ce
que nous avons à dire et qui sont plus
occupés à discuter et à rigoler entre
eux
allez allez monsieur vallée
merci monsieur le Président au moment
d'aborder l'étude de l'article 7
monsieur le rapporteur a parlé d'une
équation qui n'aurait que deux facteurs
pourtant rien n'interdisait dans
l'introduire d'autres ils ont tous été
refusés mais encore une fois avec si peu
d'explications de vote c'est pour cela
que d'autres parlent pour vous et que
faute de mieux nous sommes obligés
d'aller les écouter c'est le cas d'Alain
main qui penseur organique de la droite
et de la macronie qui écument ces
jours-ci les plateaux télé et je vais le
citer en mettant bien les guillemets
pour être sûr de ne pas le plagier lui
qui comme auteur pluri condamné pour
contrefaçon a déjà brillé par un
comportement fautif en la matière mais
au moins lui il parle sans sur moi et
sans pudeur je le cite dans la vie on a
l'obligation de bien parler à son
banquier fin de citation comme si ceux
qui triment en fin de moi ne le savaient
pas plus que les autres et notamment
ceux qui sacrifient du salaire pour
faire grève comme aujourd'hui encore je
poursuis on ne paye que 5% de taux
d'intérêt en plus que l’allemagne ce qui
finalement est une bénédiction imméritée
pour la France on saluera l'esprit
patriotique du monsieur qui confine au
masochisme et enfin ouvrez les
guillemets celle-là était encadré le
marché est un être primaire s'il voit
qu'on a changé l'âge il considéra que la
France est enfin un pays sérieux fin de
citation pour être sérieux il faut donc
être injuste tout est dit par ce
monsieur sans filtre et sans honte le
marché primaire alors soyons le avec lui
si c'est ça le projet ce serait déposé
les armes devant la brutalité de la vie
et sacrifier l'honneur de la politique à
l'appétit insatiable du marché fut un
temps hanté maastrichien où vous
proclamiez avec le général que la
politique de la France ne se faisait pas
à la corbeille c'est là-dessus qu'on a
envie de vous entendre ne laissez pas
les autres parler à votre place manque
n’est rien le peuple qui a défilé
aujourd'hui et tout exprimez-vous comme
nous vous le disons aujourd'hui pour
vous demander le retrait
merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues puisque notre collègue Alain
Milon a convoqué ici même Spinoza
sachons ensemble finalement continuer de
comprendre ce réel qui sous-tend le
pacte social parce que je demeure
convaincu messieurs les ministres que
oui la retraite dans notre pays en
France à travers son histoire constitue
un des piliers fondamental de ce pacte
social et je veux ce soir rendre hommage
à celui qui en 1884 fut un des
inspirateurs de la première loi sur les
caisses de secours et de retraite de la
loi
Waldeck-Rousseau ce n'est autre que
Michel Rondet cette habitant de la
commune de La Ricamarie au cœur de la
vallée de londène dans le département de
la Loire de cévaler ouvrière terre de
solidarité et de fraternité je veux ce
soir aussi rendre hommage à cet homme
embrasse croisa qui au lendemain de la
seconde guerre mondiale a su si bien un
carnet c'est héritage du Conseil
National de la Résistance ou gaulliste
et communiste se disait que pour
reconstruire la France nous avions
besoin à travers d'un pacte social de la
sécurité sociale et d'une branche
vieillesse qui prenait en compte ce
nouveau temps de la vie inévitablement
ce pacte social a évolué parce que la
société a évolué nous en sommes à
bientôt près de 80 ans cependant année
après année la retraite n'a jamais perdu
de son utilité sociale de ces femmes et
de ces hommes présents dans nos communes
de ces femmes et de ces hommes présents
dans les associations de ces jeunes
retraités qui aujourd'hui donnent tout
leur sens à ce que doit être la retraite
un moment du troisième du quatrième âge
de la vie personnelle mais aussi un
moment de la vie collective de celle où
l'on rend à la société qui nous a tant
donné
mais sur les ministres votre projet de
loi aujourd'hui ne répond plus à ce
pacte social en ce sens nous ne votons
pas l'article 7
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre collègues enfin l'article 7
centre de cette réforme dimanche je vous
ai parlé de mon rêve ou plutôt de mon
cauchemar d'une corde de livreur à vélo
de 65 ans qui venait vous livrer trop
lentement des plaques qui arrivent et
froid déclenchant votre courroux un
collègue de la majorité m'a précisé dans
le couloir qu'effectivement certains
métiers on ne peut pas les faire toute
sa vie d'ailleurs c'est vous monsieur
Dussault lors d'une conférence de presse
du 10 janvier qui avait dit je cite la
reconversion est le meilleur moyen de
prévenir l'usure professionnelle pour
les salariés les plus exposés pourtant
votre gouvernement a retiré les critères
de pénibilité le livreur à vélo qui n'a
rien d'autre rigole devant votre propos
l'agriculteur que je suis rigole de même
la reconversion est un luxe qui n'est
pas accessible à tous et qui ne peut
justifier votre réforme dorénavant
matinée ici d'une perspective de
capitalisation une réforme injuste que
vous faites payer au seul salarié car
vous refusez toutes nos propositions
d'alternatives financières préférant
d'accès les gens sur leur vie plutôt que
d'aller chercher l'argent là où il est
en abondance les Français voulant dit
massivement aujourd'hui renoncer à cet
article 7 et à cette réforme je vous
remercie
le président
j'aimerais rappeler ici dans ce temple
de la Raison laïque et un peu trop
instrumental que tu gagneras ta vie à la
sueur de ton front n'allait pas accusé
l'origine de cette phrase et que l'une
des racines latines de travail c'est
tripalium c'est instrument de torture
vous avez beaucoup le progrès s'est rivé
l'homme à son établi
le sens de l'histoire c'est précisément
émanciper l'homme soit par la technique
soit par des lois c'est parce que vous
êtes en train de faire vous êtes à
contre histoire c'est une méchanceté
infligée au peuple des travailleurs la
France défile dans les rues le président
est muré dans le silence et dans son
palais et Laurence Rossignol a
parfaitement raison de dire nous sommes
dans une impasse démocratique et à
limite on pourrait dire ce que d'aucun
récuse et que je partage
le peuple la représentation légale n'est
pas la représentation réelle oui vous
avez là à mon sens en étant sourd et
aveugle vous avez là un abus de majorité
et vous faites preuve de majorité
tyrannique le peuple l'oubliera pas et
c'est vous je le dis qui fait le lit du
Front National et des extrêmes demain
vous serez comptable de cela et je le
dis sans le souhaiter parce que je suis
en républicain conséquent ce que vous
faites en étant fermé vous aurez vous
appelez à la radicalisation et vous
appelez aux violences et il faut en
sortir et le seul et le seul façon de
sortir c'est de retirer ce texte
monsieur Cabanel
rassemblement
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je comprends tout à fait les
arguments qui ont été développés et j'en
partage beaucoup notamment sur le projet
un projet de loi travail qui aurait dû
précéder un projet retraite mais je
voudrais quand même apporter mon
éclairage
d'un côté effectivement le report de
l'âge de 62 à 64 ans d'ici 2030
et de l'autre la loi Touraine sous le
mandat donc de François Hollande aux
responsabilités qui je pense est une
bonne loi et qui est en vigueur depuis
je prends l'exemple d'un jeune de 21 ans
qui commence à travailler et qu'il veut
et s'il veut atteindre son taux plein
devra travailler jusqu'à 64 ans 64 ans
si il a un
un
salaire modeste
2000 euros brut s'il veut partir à la
retraite à 62 ans parce que je suppose
que vous voulez rester à 62 ans
mais il aura une décote
une dicotte de 5%
100 euros par mois de moins alors que
ici et là nous sommes tous d'accord pour
que effectivement les pensions soient
les plus hautes possibles pour les
futurs retraités donc je crois que il
est important pour nous à travers donc
ce projet de loi qui nous est présenté
et même si je partage le fait que il est
pas dans un dans un au niveau de du
projet de loi de finance c'est pas le
véhicule législatif il y a quand même
donc d'autres articles notamment le 8 et
le 9 sur la pénibilité sur la retraite
progressive sur le droit des femmes sur
les carrières longues ou à mon sens là
nous devons apporter tous les éléments
pour assurer les Français
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre pour collègues qui se sont
exprimés précédemment je demande la
suppression de cet article pour trois
raisons d'abord parce que on a
l'impression avec ce texte que
l'important est le rallongement du
nombre d'années travaillées 65 puis
maintenant 64
est devenu un totem finalement pour
démontrer que vous réussissez là où vous
prédécesseurs ont échoué ou peut-être
non pas osé afin que cette réforme
figure parmi les autres au tableau
d'honneur d'un président qui se veut
réformiste ensuite parce que l'ampleur
des manifestations aujourd'hui est la
démonstration vous n'avez pas pris en
compte un changement radical dans le
rapport au travail dans la société
française accélérée et certainement
amplifiée par la crise covid enfin parce
que dans quelques heures nous serons le
8 mars et je ne doute pas qu'un nombre
de gestes symboliques qui ne coûte pas
cher certes seront faits pour nous
rappeler la grande cause du quinquennat
précédent le droit des femmes avec très
très fort vous le referez pour ce 8 mars
2023 le droit de travailler plus pour
gagner moins et une retraite à minima
parce qu'elles n'auront pas pour
beaucoup d'entre elles les 43 à nuités
en continu parce qu'elles n'auront pas
l'argent nécessaire pour contribuer à
une assurance ou un fond de pension
privée pour compléter une retraite
minimum parce qu'elles auront abandonné
leur carrière en France pour suivre leur
conjoint en partant à l'étranger et
auront une fine et des carrières hachées
des cotisations faibles voire
inexistantes et pourtant vous leur
demandez de travailler deux ans de plus
si vous leur promettez une retraite de
misère alors les plus beaux gestes que
vous pourrez faire pour les Françaises
en ce 8 mars 2023 et de retirer votre
réforme
Châtillon
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre chers collègue je
ne vais pas m'exprimer en tant que
sénateur mais en tant qu' ancien chef
d'entreprise pendant 38 ans dans
l'agroalimentaire
je voudrais qu'au-delà de ce ces
discussions que nous avons depuis
quelques jours vous puissiez réfléchir
un problème majeur nous sommes dans un
monde de compétition
j'ai connu des entreprises qui étaient
en Allemagne qui était dans le nord de
l'Europe et qui avait effectivement
beaucoup plus compétitivité que la nôtre
nous sommes passés de 10 milliards
d'exportation il y a trois ans à moins
de milliards cette année dans
l'agroalimentaire donc je vous invite à
réfléchir aujourd'hui s'il vous plaît
aujourd'hui on vous a écouté aujourd'hui
la compétition la compétitivité dans un
monde avec la Chine les États-Unis
l'Inde et bien d'autres pays nous oblige
à être véritablement compétition le
problème n'est pas toujours de régler le
problème des rémunérations je vous
rappelle que le Medef a fait un accord
avec les syndicats pour dans quelques
jours proposer une réglementation qui
permettra la capitalisation vers
l'indemnité mais en même temps le
principe de capitalisation qui est un
sujet intéressant et important donc je
vous invite à réfléchir sachez que
l'avenir appartient à ceux qui sont à
même d'apporter aux autres des raisons
de vivre et d'espérer c'est ce que nous
souhaitons ici merci
monsieur le président Bruno Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
je me souviens parfaitement c'était en
octobre 2010
et nous étions sur ces mêmes bancs le 12
octobre une énorme manifestation une
énorme mobilisation 3 millions de
personnes
j'étais ici
je soutenais cette réforme
et je me souviens les mêmes arguments
souvent caricaturaux le même ton un prêt
à toi la réforme est votée vous arrivez
ensuite au pouvoir l'avez-vous aboli non
vous ne l'avez pas aboli
vous l'avez
vous l'avez durci avec les 43 à nuités
de la réforme Touraine c'est ça la
vérité c'est ça le double langage ça
signifie aujourd'hui pour des Français
qui arrivent à 22 ans sur le marché du
travail un départ à taux plein un départ
à 65 ans voilà votre double langage oui
cette réforme nous l'avons déjà voté ici
nous l'assumons nous assumons le critère
d'âge nous l'assumons parce que c'est un
levier qui nous permettra de sauver le
régime des retraites c'est un levier
efficace c'est aussi parce que c'est un
filet de sécurité vous enlevez cette
borne d'âge et alors vous aurez une
machine à des côtes parce que vous savez
parfaitement que c'est ce qui crée des
retraités pauvres vous savez aussi que
la décote des plus modestes c'est le
double par rapport au décote des cadres
alors oui nous l'assumons nous
l'assumons parce que cette borne d'âge
permettra non seulement de sauver la
réforme et le régime par répartition et
même si la réforme est provisoirement un
populaire nous en avons connu d'autres
mais quand on est et quand on fait de la
politique on assume ce qui est bon pour
le pays et cette réforme à terme elle ne
sera pas abrogée pas plus que vous
n'aviez abrogé la précédente
Monsieur Martin lévrier
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président
nos prédécesseurs nous ont laissé une
extraordinaire un extraordinaire système
de solidarité intergénée
intergénérationnelle c'est le système de
répartition de nos retraites qui nous
obligent à avoir systématiquement un
équilibre entre les actifs et les
pensionnés
nous savons tous aujourd'hui que cette
ce système est déséquilibré et de
redevenu fragile nous le savons tous et
nous en connaissons tous les raisons et
nous en connaissons tous les solutions
possibles des solutions possibles il y
en avait trois je ne répéterai pas nous
avons choisi celle du déplacement de
l'âge de la retraite et vous savez aussi
pourquoi alors on peut nous dire c'est
une réforme de droite parce
qu'effectivement les amendements ont été
portés depuis quatre ans par la droite
ici mais on pourrait aussi dire que
c'est une réforme de gauche quand on
regarde les articles qui suivent
l'article 7 monsieur le Président vous
comprendrez pourquoi on parle rarement
puisque c'est assez difficile avec la
avec ce qui se passe ici
je vous rappelle je vous rappelle que
les efforts qui sont faits dans cette
loi sont de l'ordre les efforts sociaux
sont de l'ordre de 6 milliards et demi
ils étaient de l'ordre de 1 milliard
pour la réforme verte et de 4 milliards
pour la réforme Touraine c'est important
de le rappeler
cette réforme elle nous paraît aussi
très importante parce qu'elle rappelle
les relations du travail moi j'entends à
ma gauche depuis 5 jours maintenant une
enfin ma droite pardon vous avez raison
Unis une image une image du travail qui
est assez pitoyable qui est assez
pitoyable et qui montre à le travail
comme de l'aliénation moi je crois au
travail comme l'épanouissement aussi
enfin vous ne vous le dites très très
rarement
enfin enfin je vous rappelle que c'est
une réforme et moi j'y crois beaucoup
qui est faite pour les jeunes quand j'ai
eu 30 ans quand j'ai commencé à
travailler à 25 ans on m'a dit que je
n'aurais pas de retraite je ne veux pas
dire aux jeunes de 25 ans aujourd'hui
qu'il n'auront pas de retraite tout cela
pour vous dire que le manque de courage
c'est cela qui fait le lit des extrêmes
madame Robert
monsieur
Beauregard pardonnez-moi
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je vais commencer par dire notre
collègue Retailleau qu'il est exact que
nous avons pas remis en cause la réforme
de retraite que vous avez vous-même mis
en œuvre de la même manière vous n'avez
pas remis en cause les 35 heures ni le
mariage pour tous
au-delà de ça
au-delà de ça mes chers collègues je
pense que nous traversons une période
particulière où notre démocratie
véritablement est en danger
et je pense qu'à travers cette loi nous
jouons un peu avec le feu d'abord sur la
forme
parce que les organisations syndicales
pour la première fois depuis très
longtemps sont unis qu'il n'a pas été
compte de ce tenu compte pardon de ce
qu'elle proposait et qu'elles ont été
laissés en quelque sorte sur le bord du
chemin
sur le fond ça a été rapide tout à
l'heure mais je vais y revenir quelques
instants
depuis 2010 et même plus que cela notre
société a considérablement changé
le covid est passé par là certes c'est
si vrai que dans les accueils de pignon
nous voyons que
ceux qui sont proches de la retraite
préfèrent finalement faire deux années
d'au moins de travail et on envisageant
une diminution sensible de leur pouvoir
d'achat c'était l'inverse de ce qu'il
déclarait voici seulement deux ou trois
ans
depuis
les présidentielles sont passés par là
et aux élections présidentielles que ce
soit la candidate de la droite ou la
candidate de la gauche ou Emmanuel
Macron qui a fait moins de 20% que le
total des voies de l'extrême droite
montre bien que notre démocratie est en
danger c'est la raison pour laquelle je
pense que l'assemblée des territoires et
le 8e hérissent qu'il a soutient à une
importance très forte et qu'il faut
faire preuve d'une grande responsabilité
d'écoute et d'attention et ne pas dire
qu'on met en place ce que nous avions
prévu voici 4 ans alors que depuis 4 ans
beaucoup de choses ont changé madame
Robert
merci Monsieur le le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues la vie
doit toujours porter en elle une lueur
d'espoir car la fin de l'espoir elle au
commencement de la mort je pense que
beaucoup d'entre vous ici reconnaissent
cette phrase du général de Gaulle
hors reculer l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans donne comme
perspective aux françaises et aux
Français qu'il n'auraient peut-être pas
d'autres choix que de cesser leur vie au
travail au moment où ils ne seront pas
capables de la vivre en bonne santé et
on pense bien sûr à tout cela les plus
vulnérables les plus précaires les
femmes celles et ceux qui ont commencé
tôt à travailler et qui considère tout
simplement que cette réforme est brutale
alors pourquoi
n'écoutez-vous pas celles et ceux qui
crient cette injustice pourquoi
n'entendez-vous pas ces millions de
Françaises et Français qui aujourd'hui
vous ont dit qu'ils n'en veulent pas
c'est une affaire de légitimité et cela
devient une question démocratique alors
Monsieur le Ministre ayez du courage
abandonner c'est très forme et on pourra
peut-être faire raisonner en nous cette
citation de Voltaire qui disait la
retraite et ce port heureux où l'on peut
se réfugier après les orages de la vie
Monsieur Olivier non pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres vous nous avez dit
plusieurs fois que nous étions
silencieux que nous avions peur de
parler non simplement on a une obsession
c'est celle d'aller au bout du texte et
aller au bout du texte c'est la
responsabilité
je suis sorti de mes gonds tout à
l'heure quand j'ai entendu le sénateur
qui est rouge qui a interpellé le
ministre sur ses origines sociales
ça ne vous grandit pas c'est le marxisme
le plus terrible
oui
figurez-vous sénateur qui est rouge
moi
j'ai eu d'enfance heureuse j'ai pas
souffert dans ma vie et pourtant je
crois que je sais que généreux avec les
plus modestes d'entre nous et je
revendique cette qualité vous avez
appelé Marx j'appelle Max Weber
l'éthique de conviction mais surtout
l'éthique de responsabilité
monsieur kaner vous avez tout à l'heure
dit que nous étions en train de revivre
le clivage droite-gauche oh je vois bien
que vous souhaitez ça mais nous ne
sommes plus en 1981 pourquoi parce que
les Français ne vous croient plus comme
ça a été dit tout à l'heure quand vous
êtes au pouvoir quand vous êtes au
pouvoir vous choisissez la
responsabilité vous choisissez la
réforme Touraine et quand vous êtes dans
l'opposition vous choisissez
l'indignation vous choisissez une forme
d'irresponsabilité une forme de
démagogie mais méfiez-vous
électoralement ça ne vous grandit pas ce
sont les populistes qui sont à la porte
c'est eux qui encaissent votre
comportement et votre responsabilité
et nous nous choisissons le la
responsabilité parce que pour nous la
responsabilité c'est la meilleure
antidote au populisme je vous remercie
merci
Monsieur Lucia scandione
messieurs les ministres en définitif je
serai très court
tout a été pratiquement dit par mes
collègues oui mais je peux
je peux encore le répéter si vous le
souhaitez
cette réforme est mauvaise et c'est un
coup bas pour les Français
mauvaise pour les Français qui vont être
frappés par la mesure que vous prenez
mais qu'est-ce qui vous a pris pourquoi
êtes-vous engagé dans cette aventure
vous êtes aveuglé par les mesures que
vous prenez vous même mais je crois que
vous êtes aveuglé par l'engagement du
président de la République dans cette
démarche funeste vous avez peut-être
même peur de ce président qui va imposer
ce triste sort à nos compatriotes
d'ailleurs ici il n'y a pas que vous qui
êtes aveuglé par ce président de la
République qui ne s'occupe pas des
Français lui qui a obtenu moins de 30%
des voix du des Français au premier tour
et qui a été élu car personne ne voulait
de la candidate du RN alors nous allons
vous aider que les ministres n'ayez pas
peur aujourd'hui 3 millions de Français
ont manifesté plusieurs millions sont en
grève c'est un signal courage ayez du
courage
retirer cet article 7 numéro 7 retirez
cette mauvaise loi Madame De Marco
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues je vais relier
retraite et climat ce sont deux
questions majeures qui sont pourtant
liées cette réforme des retraites repose
sur un postulat productiviste travaillez
plus encore plus longtemps qu'importe
encore qu'importe la pénibilité les
conditions de travail
pour toi pourtant soigner le présent
c'est préparer l'avenir c'est ça serait
une retraite digne à toute et toute et
garantir justement ce droit à la
retraite aux prochaines générations côté
climat nous subissons déjà les
conséquences de l'inaction climatique et
justement elle frappe les plus
vulnérables
soignez le présent et préparer l'avenir
c'est agir aujourd'hui pour préserver
notre planète pour protéger les hommes
et les femmes qui vivent c'est avec
cette réforme de la retraite que nous
prévoyons pas la venir
ce n'est pas sérieux nous ne sommes pas
à la hauteur des enjeux aujourd'hui je
me permets de terminer par une citation
de Pablo Neruda
poète chilien mais aussi sénateur
il meurt lentement celui qui ne change
pas de cap
alors je vous dis aujourd'hui il est
encore temps de changer de cap merci
bien
alors
monsieur le ministre vous vouliez
intervenir
merci monsieur le Président juste
quelques mots pour répondre aux
différents intervenants de cette
discussion générale sur l'article
d'abord pour dire que
merci Monsieur président d'abord pour
dire que si nous présentons cette
réforme et si nous avons fait le choix
de proposer au Parlement l'adoption cet
article 7 avec des mesures qu'on
qualifie parfois de paramétrique parce
que tout à fait entre nous entre
paramétriques et systémique parfois la
confusion peut régner et ce qui
systémique systémique à un moment
s'accompagne généralement de critères
paramétriques pour fonctionner mais
parfois il y a une volonté divisée
peut-être de manière un peu arbitraire
les choses dans la matière pourquoi
est-ce que nous avons présenté cette
mesure là d'abord parce que je l'ai dit
à plusieurs reprises je le dis très vite
le système de retraite que nous
connaissons pour des raisons
essentiellement démographiques n'est pas
un système équilibré et donc il y a un
équilibre financier à retrouver un
déficit à combler et par ailleurs nous
souhaitons financer de nouveaux droits
des nouveaux droits en matière
pénibilité des nouveaux droits en
matière de prise en compte des carrières
longues des nouveaux droits en matière
de niveau minimum de pension des
nouveaux droits aussi sur la question de
la prévention et de l'emploi des seniors
et lorsque l'on finance des nouveaux
droits lorsque l'on crée de nouveau
droit en même temps qu'on crée de
nouveaux droits on crée de nouvelles
dépenses c'est très normal et donc il
nous faut trouver des recettes qui
permettent d'atteindre cette équilibre
nous avons regardé les choses et parfois
j'entends mais pourquoi est-ce que vous
ne vous seriez pas contenté si je puis
dire d'accélérer la mise en œuvre de la
réforme Touraine de 2013 parce que
l'accélération de la réforme Touraine de
2013 c'est 2 milliards 3 en 2025 les
4000 exercices en 2030 le déficit en
2030 c'est 13005 et la réforme que nous
vous proposons permet de générer 17,7
milliards d'euros sur les seules mesures
paramétriques et avec les quelques
mesures financières que nous ajoutons
d'arriver à 19,5 milliards d'euros de
recettes ce qui permettra de financer à
la fois le déficit de 2030 et le
financement des nouvelles mesures c'est
la première fois depuis plus de 30 ans
parmi les cinq dernières réformes des
retraites que la part des économies des
recettes générées par la réforme est
aussi importante pour ce qui est pour ce
qui concerne le financement de nouveaux
droits et de mesure d'accompagnement
social
j'ai en tête que la réforme de 2010 et
j'ai aussi en tête que le déficit a à
résorbé était beaucoup plus important du
fait de la crise financière mais la
réforme de 2010 consacrée 6% des
recettes générées au financement de
nouveaux droits et aux mesures
d'accompagnement social nous sommes à
33% de financement des mesures
d'accompagnement social et nous le
faisons avec une volonté qui est de
protéger les plus fragiles les celles et
ceux souvent celles qui sont amenées à
travailler le plus tard possible et
c'est vrai la raison pour laquelle de la
même manière c'est la première fois
qu'un relèvement de l'âge légal de
départ et la retraite ne s'accompagne
pas d'un relèvement de l'âge
d'annulation de la décote nous le
maintenons à 67 ans de la même manière
mais j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
précédemment que nous maintenons les
âges de départ anticipés notamment pour
les travailleurs handicapés mais pas
seulement et le fait de maintenir l'âge
de suppression de la décote est une
vraie mesure de protection
j'ai enfin entendu dans les différentes
interventions un certain nombre de
reproches de critiques d'interrogations
sur le caractère juste ou injuste du
système de retraite mais en réalité et
je dis en regardant les bandes de la
gauche c'est de là que ça venait
ce que vous ne reprochez ce que vous
reprochez au système de retraite ça
n'est pas tant la réforme que le système
actuel vous reprochez l'impact les
conséquences des carrières hachées sur
le calcul des pensions particulièrement
des femmes vous reprochez l'absence de
prise en compte suffisante de la
pénibilité alors que nous vous proposons
d'avancer vous reprochez le faible
niveau des retraites et finalement vous
nous reprochez d'avoir le courage de
faire ce que vous n'avez jamais eu le
courage de faire et c'est ce que nous
faisons avec cette réforme et je vais un
peu je vais même un peu plus loin si
s'il s'agissait de voir nous convaincre
un peu plus mais le président Retailleau
m'a précédé pour une partie de cette
démonstration aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous faites de
grandes déclarations vous évoquez de
grands auteurs que l'on pourrait
peut-être laisser en paix mais vous avez
posé de grands auteurs pour dire votre
opposition absolue à la réforme
regardons ce qui s'est passé depuis le
début des années 80 pas une réforme des
retraites quelle que soit l'ardeur avec
laquelle elle a été combattue et je
prends ma part pas une réforme des
retraites n'a été remise en cause par
une quelconque alternance que ce soit
pas une et celle-ci comme les autres si
un jour est aventure vous revenez au
pouvoir vous la maintiendrez vous la
maintiendrez et comme en 2013 vous
l'accentuerez parce que en 2013 est-ce
ce qui s'est passé et je l'ai voté mais
contrairement à vous je l'assume je l'ai
voté l'augmentation de la durée de
cotisation était aussi justifiée par le
fait que l'âge avait été relevé et qu'il
fallait trouver une cohérence pour
éviter justement qu'il ait discordant
entre l'âge et la durée de cotisation il
se passera exactement la même chose si
d'aventure vous deviez retrouver des
responsabilités et un esprit majoritaire
et puis enfin une dernière chose j'ai
évoqué la comparaison avec la seule
accélération de la réforme Touraine mais
il faut aller plus loin dans la
comparaison et regarder les alternatives
quelles sont les alternatives j'entends
parfois mais arrêtez avec l'âge
d'ouverture des droits et
concentrez-vous sur la durée de
cotisation nous avons fait la simulation
c'est 45 années minimum c'est 45 années
minimum dans une période où l'âge moyen
d'entrer dans la vie active est à est à
22 ans ça signifie que ceux qui ne se
concentrent que sur la durée de
cotisation créer de la décote ou accepte
la perspective d'un âge effectif de
départ à la retraite à 67 ans j'ai aussi
entendu c'est le chef de votre partie
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
socialistes monsieur fort dire on
revient à 60 ans mais avec 43 années de
cotisation c'est une machine à pauvreté
c'est une machine à décote parfois même
son numéro 2 dit que c'est une utopie et
que c'est totalement irréaliste donc
nous proposons quelque chose qui est
protecteur protecteur parce que ça
permet de garantir l'égalité protecteur
parce que ça permet de garantir la
pérennité du système sans financement
sans retour à l'équilibre et le
financement des nouveaux droits c'est la
raison sont les raisons pour lesquelles
monsieur le Président est j'irai plus
vite sur les 70 ou 72 je crois un moment
de suppression mais comme il s'agit de
supprimer des dispositions auxquelles
nous sommes attachés j'ai essayé de vous
le démontrer j'irai plus vite pour
donner tout à l'heure des avis
défavorables
merci nous allons commencer
l'examen de 77
amendements qui font qui sont identiques
et qui sont les amendements de
suppression l'amendement numéro 3 Madame
A poursuppoli
merci monsieur le Président l'article 7
et le cœur de réacteurs du projet de loi
cet article 7 prévoit d'allonger l'âge
légal de 3 mois par an dès septembre
2023 pour atteindre 64 ans 2030 quand
62 aujourd'hui cet article s'est inscrit
dans la durée le principe d'un
allongement de la durée de cotisation
nécessaire pour obtenir une retraite à
taux plein la durée de cotisation est
relevée d'un trimestre tous les trois
ans jusqu'en 2035 pour atteindre 172
trimestres soit 44 ans pour les
générations nées en 73 et suivantes le
pouvoir accélère la réforme Touraine
contre laquelle nous nous étions opposés
sur les banques communistes
tous les salariés vont devoir travailler
davantage même ceux qui exercent des
métiers pénibles et à cet instant je
pense aux salariés de l'agroalimentaire
qui travaille dans le froid à la chaîne
qui feront les qui font les trois huit
femmes comme homme comme un Moïse dans
le Pas-de-Calais qui sont usés je pense
au sous aux ouvriers aux salariés qui
travaillent en fonderie à 1400 degrés à
Arc International ou à stellantis je
pense aux ouvriers des ports aux agents
de police aux sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels aux égoutiers qui devront
travailler au moins jusqu'à 59 ans
contre 57 aujourd'hui ainsi les Français
passeront moins de temps à la retraite
toutes ces réformes successives ont
organisé la paupérisation de nombreux
retraités avec cet article vous actez le
retour aux années 70 ou la retraite
était à 65 ans contrairement au
gouvernement qui veut faire un retour
dans le passé nous voulons aller vers
l'avenir en réduisant le temps de
travail et en réduisant le temps passé
au travail en partant à la retraite à 60
ans je vous remercie madame Cohen
merci monsieur le Président plus le
texte de la réforme des retraites avance
plus l'injustice sociale du projet
claque au grand jour elle est unique
elle est injustifiée nous avons nous
l'avons démontré depuis le début de nos
discussions pour toutes et tous moins de
2,5% des futurs retraités concernés par
une revalorisation à 1200 euros par la
réforme moins de 1,5% des retraités
actuels verront leur pension franchir le
seuil des 1200 euros mais comme
visiblement vous n'entendez ni les
arguments du peuple dans la rue ni ceux
des parlementaires de gauche ici présent
laissez-moi faire référence à un appel
de personnalité qui elles aussi sont
exprimé leur refus de cette réforme le
18 janvier dernier plus de 100
personnalités ont rédigé une tribune
pour dénoncer les dangers de ce projet
des personnes des personnalités issues
de la culture des économistes des
sociologues des philosophes des
historiens qui participent à la vie
intellectuelle de notre les pays et à
son rayonnement et qui toutes s'unissent
pour écrire
contre cette réforme je cite Annie
Ernaux prix Nobel de littérature Barbara
Carlotti compositrice Lydie Salvert
écrivaine et j'en passe l'objectif je
les cite l'objectif de cette réforme à
rebours de l'histoire sociale et de
faire travailler plus et plus longtemps
des femmes et des hommes qui aspirent au
repos et a donné libre cours à leurs
projets dans un moment privilégié de la
vie pour y parvenir le gouvernement
tente de nous enfermer dans une querelle
budgétaire et comptable vous l'avez
exprimé admin de reprise la réforme va
frapper plus durement ce qui exerce des
métiers les plus difficiles
usant tant physiquement que
psychologiquement et qui ont moins de
chance de profiter d'une retraite
paisible et de s'imaginer un avenir
après 64 ans le report de l'âge légal
n'a aucun effet sur les plus diplômés et
fait peser la charge entièrement sur les
- 10
voilà pourquoi nous demandons la
suppression de cet article
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement vise à supprimer l'article
relatif au recul de l'âge de départ
obligatoire à 64 ans d'ici à 2030 il y a
quelques heures monsieur le ministre
Attal parler d'équilibre du système de
retraite pour les prochaines années moi
je souhaite vous parler d'équilibre
entre une vie complète au travail et un
droit au repos ce droit au repos n'est
pas un caprice c'est la possibilité de
s'épanouir et de profiter des siens
après avoir contribué tout au long de sa
vie à la dynamique économique de notre
pays
cette mesure est inéquitable est injuste
pour tous ceux qui ont des parcours
hachés en premier lieu les femmes pour
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler tôt
et pour ceux qui ont exposés à des
métiers pénibles cette mesure est
également brutale puisqu'elle
s'appliquera dès le 1er septembre 2023
et concernera des personnes très proches
du départ à la retraite cette mesure est
enfin disproportionnée par rapport aux
prévisions et nous pensons que d'autres
moyens auraient pu être proposé pour
résorber ce déficit tout ceci est le
sens de notre amendement de suppression
merci
merci monsieur le Président alors moi je
ne reprochais je ne reprocherai pas
monsieur le ministre de ne pas faire une
réforme de gauche c'est normal et encore
moins une réforme écologiste c'est
normal vous êtes de droite et
productiviste effectivement il faudrait
il faudrait pour faire une autre réforme
il faudrait une autre répartition des
richesses vous avez montré que vous ne
savez pas le faire et vous ne savez
encore moins passer de la notion de
croissance à la notion de prospérité il
faudrait avoir le projet de changer le
travail et sa place dans la vie vous
vous ne pensez qu'à l'intensifier pour
produire plus de profit très rapidement
je vais vous dire pourquoi c'est une
réforme de droite parce que les en fait
si vous pouvez me permettez de parler
sans être interrompu merci
donc oui je vais vous dire pourquoi
c'est une réforme de droite parce que
c'est sur les travailleurs et sur eux
seuls que vous allez faire les économies
10 milliards en leur payant pas de
pension pendant deux ans et c'est eux
qui vont vous apporter des recettes les
7 milliards encore en cotisation et et
en impôts donc c'est eux 17 milliards
c'est eux qui vous apportent toute la
réforme et quant à vos 3 milliards 3 est
pas six de mesure d'atténuation de la
brutalité de de la réforme c'est pris
sur ces 18 milliards ce sont les
travailleurs qui se les payent c'est pas
les employeurs c'est pas l'état c'est
personne d'autre sur les 18 milliards il
y a effectivement 16% qui va atténuer
les les la brutalité de la réforme et
c'est 16% et c'est pas 33% et c'est les
travailleurs qui se les payent
monsieur le Président Gautard
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur le monsieur le Président
depuis le début de cette réforme le
gouvernement s'obstine a répété en
boucle un mensonge ce recul de l'âge de
départ en retraite serait inévitable il
serait la seule solution pour résoudre
le futur déficit de nos systèmes de
retraite cependant nous l'avons répété à
maintes reprises c'est faux faux et faux
ce report de l'âge légal est un choix du
gouvernement et un choix injuste le
choix de faire reposer tous les efforts
sur les épaules des travailleurs et des
travailleuses particulièrement les plus
précaires celles et ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler les plus jeunes et
qui ont des carrières incomplètes pire
encore cette réforme est brutale et ne
prévoit à peu près pas de mesure
d'accompagnement votre choix est de ne
pas redistribuer les richesses et de ne
pas les prendre en compte à l'inverse
depuis le début de cette réforme nous
martelons la même chose il existe des
alternatives à la fois socialement et
écologiquement juste pour renforcer
justement notre système de retraite que
vous avez méthodiquement refusé
l'élargissement de l'assiette des
cotisations et dividendes l'augmentation
des la réduction des inégalités de
salaire entre femmes et les hommes ou
encore la semaine de 30 des heures sur
quatre jours il y a à dire vrai des
dizaines de milliards d'euros de
financement possible qui mettrait à
rebours de votre projet de revenir
progressivement vers l'âge de départ de
60 ans que nous défendons et nous le
ferons monsieur le ministre nous le
répétons cette réforme est injuste elle
aura un nombre d'impact négatifs
importants sur le chômage des seigneurs
des seniors sur notre tissu associatif
sur notre démocratie locale j'y
reviendrai et surtout surtout sur le
quotidien des Français et des Françaises
ceux qui devront travailler deux ans de
plus mais aussi leurs enfants et
petits-enfants monsieur le ministre plus
personne ne croit à votre projet à votre
réforme est-ce qu'il reste de votre
majorité se fissure petit à petit votre
seul créneau travaillait plus votre
absence de vision de manque
d'imagination votre dogmatisme vous
empêche de voir l'évolution de notre
société
tu es Bénin roche
notre système de retraite par
répartition auquel nous sommes tous très
attachés il me semble enfin je l'espère
n'est pas menacé
il exécutif dramatise la situation qu'il
a un peu créé lui-même de manière
caricaturale il attaque notamment à ses
calculs le poids des pensions des
fonctionnaires sous financés par l'État
ce qui est une hérésie l'objectif est de
faire une réforme budgétaire en ne
sollicitant que les efforts des
travailleurs sans jamais remettre en
cause la gabegie d'aide aux entreprises
sans aucune contrepartie la baisse
permanente des impôts sur les
entreprises le renoncement la lutte
contre l'optimisation fiscale ou encore
la course à l'extravagance financière
qui déséquilibre chaque jour un peu plus
la répartition des richesses cette
présentation caricaturale d'un besoin
urgent de réforme du système de retraite
se part d'attention noble toutes plus
fausse les unes que les autres la vérité
est tout autre les femmes codent parmi
les grandes victimes de cette réforme
avec l'annulation de l'effet
bonificateur de maternité les
travailleurs et travailleuses ayant
commencé à travailler tôt vont
travailler encore davantage et seule une
petite partie minime des retraités sera
concernés par la mesure de 1200 euros
mensuels le reste des mesures
d'accompagnement de la disposition du
recul de l'âge ne sont que des
tentatives d'amortissement des
conséquences de cette disposition est
juste la chance et le drame du pays
c'est que les citoyens et citoyens
salariés fonctionnaires se sont aperçus
de ces contre-vérités en même temps
qu'il ne se découvrait aucune appétence
pour travailler dans des organisations
où il se sent très souvent indésirables
à l'âge de 55 ans c'est une chance parce
qu'il ne manifeste dans des cortèges
d'une importance inédite à Paris est en
province c'est un drame parce que le
gouvernement reste sourd à une
argumentation technique solide ancrée
dans la réalité du travail le
gouvernement reste sourd à cette volonté
populaire et l'incompréhension à laisser
place à l'indignation ainsi qu'à la
colère il ne s'agit pas seulement
d'empêcher l'adoption et la mise en
place d'un dispositif à juste il s'agit
également de redonner à la nation
confiance dans la réalité la vigueur de
sa démocratie et de maintenir une
cohésion sociale menacée nous vous
demandons donc solennellement de voter
le rejet de ce projet de loi et plus
particulièrement de son article 7 madame
compta si monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues des
millions de Françaises et Français sont
descendus dans la rue partout en France
pour la sixième journée de mobilisation
contre votre réforme des retraites
injuste brutale et cyniquement négocié
avec la droite au soutien de ces
millions manifestants 80% des salariés
s'opposent à votre projet de réforme ils
disent non au report à 64 ans de l'âge
légal la fin du travail des enfants le
repos dominical est congés payés la
semaine de 40-39-35 heures et bien sur
les retraites démontent que libérer le
travail et l'horizon depuis le 19e
siècle des luttes sociales et du sens du
progrès humain pourtant votre
gouvernement veut dans cet article
imposer de travailler plus longtemps en
repoussant l'âge légal de la retraite à
64 ans au lieu de 62 actuellement la
durée de cotisation nécessaire pour
avoir une cotisation à temps plein à
taux plat augmenterait de façon brutale
alors qu'elle était prévue de manière
plus progressive jusqu'en 2035 et vous
oubliez de dire que l'objectif de la
réforme Touraine était justement
d'éviter un report de l'âge légal
à rebours de tout progrès social votre
gouvernement prévoit des économies
exclusivement sur le départ différé en
retraite des travailleurs et sur
l'allongement de notre temps de travail
cette réforme se fait sur le dos sur la
santé des Français parce qu'il faut
réduire les déficits que vous avez
creusé déficit public déficit du
commerce extérieur c'est difficile du
mot si vous et c'est les travailleurs
qui doivent payer d'autres choix
politiques et sociaux fiscaux sont
possibles vous avez renoncié à l'ISF à
la taxation super profits à une
réflexion sur la taxation plus juste de
la valeur créée à l'augmentation des
salaires tout cela vous le faites payer
aux travailleurs pour nous c'est non il
est temps d'entend les Français de
retirer votre réforme injuste
Monsieur Arnaud
présentement vise à supprimer l'article
7 du texte nous examinons il s'agit en
ce qui me concerne en aucun cas de
manifester une opposition dogmatique
idéologique à ce projet de réforme je
présente ce projet d'amendement avec
calme sérénité et modération comme
banque nous devons bien avoir conscience
que cette réforme paramétrique répond à
nécessaire et équilibrage budgétaire
mais cette réforme est aussi un choix de
société pour les générations à venir
l'unique critère permettant de partir à
la retraite à taux plein doit être la
durée de cotisation ainsi toute personne
doit pouvoir liquider ses droits dès
lors qu'elle a acquis ses 172 trimestres
de cotisation sous réserve de la prise
en compte des critères de pénibilité en
fonction de la nature des métiers
exercés même si le gouvernement
maintient un dispositif de carrière
longue afin que les assurer
qui commence à travailler tôt puisse
partir à avant 64 ans certains assurés
commencent à travailler très tôt où les
femmes bénéficiant de trimestre acquis
au-dessus de la maternité devront
cotiser 44 ans ou plus aujourd'hui la
réalité que près de 40 % de nos
concitoyens sont prêts à avoir une
retraite minorée en partant plutôt alors
il faut laisser la possibilité à chaque
citoyen d'opérer son propre choix de vie
d'avoir son destin en main pour suivre
une activité prendre sa retraite à
partir du moment où la contribution de
chacun à la solidarité nationale
c'est-à-dire les 172 trimestres cotisés
sont réalisés
leur équilibrage financier budgétaire
peut également se concrétiser par une
réouverture du débat sur le temps et
l'organisation du travail sur un nombre
de trimestres éventuellement
complémentaires par une fiscalité plus
adaptée bref faire le travail dans le
bon ordre et pas comme cela nous est
présenté aujourd'hui je crois pouvoir
dire également que nous pourrions
considérer que la retraite pourrait se
prendre entre 60 et 67 ans suivant
l'histoire de chaque vie avec bien sûr
des pensions différentes intégrant
pénibilité
début de carrière charges familiale bref
j'en appelle un sursaut de liberté
individuelle et de choix des individus
de maîtriser leur vie au moment ils
prennent la retraite je vous invite à
soutenir cet amendement
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues c'est
amendement vise à ne pas décaler l'âge
légal de 62 à 64 ans et à ne pas
accélérer la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme Touraine j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de le dire et je le redis pour afficher
une réduction globale du déficit
structurel qu'il a lui-même aggravé en
renonçant une part importante de ses
recettes le gouvernement prévoit ses
économies exclusivement sur le départ
différé en retrait des travailleurs et
sur l'allongement du temps de travail et
pourtant cette réforme est qualifiée de
réforme de justice d'équilibre et de
progrès par la première ministre
étrange qualificatif pour une réforme
qui va encore et toujours pénaliser les
travailleurs modestes opérer une
régression sociale majeure et dont
l'utilité pour l'équilibre de notre
système de retraite reste à démontrer
cette réforme relève purement et
simplement d'un positionnement
idéologique dans le droit fil de la
politique menée maintenant depuis 2017
de désarmement fiscal et de faveur pour
les plus aisés
nous nous opposons résolument à cette
réforme et nous ne sommes pas les seuls
les millions de Françaises et Français
qui ont encore aujourd'hui battu le pavé
ne veulent pas de cette réforme
inutile pour le financement du régime
par répartition injuste pour nos
concitoyens et à rebours de tout progrès
social je vous remercie
monsieur le Président cet amendement
donc je présente vise à supprimer
l'article phare d'un projet de loi de
régression sociale inacceptable le cœur
du cœur de la réforme cet article 7 est
une mesure injustifiée injuste
inefficace et brutal plus précisément
parmi les mesures d'augmentation des
ressources du système de retraite les
mesures dites d'âge sont les mesures les
plus injustes car elles touchent
aveuglément les assurés sans tenir
compte de leur situation à l'inverse
d'autres réformes celle-ci présente le
caractère la caractéristique d'avoir un
impact immédiat en effet un travailleur
né en 1968 qui a commencé à travailler à
20 ans aurait dû partir avec 42 années
deux trimestres de cotisation avant la
réforme et bien il devra travailler
jusqu'à 64 ans après la réforme soit si
trimestre supplémentaires une partie
radon pas à la retraite en 2030 mais en
tous nos débats depuis 6 jours le prouve
votre réforme monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre est injuste et pas
utile en l'état pire elle ne fera que
des perdants et ça les Français l'ont
parfaitement compris et ils le disent
mais vous ne voulez pas les entendre
retirer votre réforme
ce
monsieur
plus efficace merci
madame arrivée
merci monsieur le président
en fait si je contribue à ces demandes
de suppression de l'amendement
essentiellement trois
raisons la première raison c'est que la
mesure d'âge est non seulement injuste
mais elle est surtout inéquitable
inéquitable parce qu'elle pénalise ceux
qui travaillent dans des conditions
difficiles qui ont des carrières longues
qui travaillent depuis longtemps et je
rejoins notre collègue centriste tout à
l'heure en disant qu'il faut raisonner
en termes de durée de cotisation plutôt
que en termes d'âge parce qu'aussi c'est
une manière de rendre la responsabilité
à chacun quelqu'un parlait d'éthique de
la responsabilité l'éthique de la
responsabilité c'est aussi renvoyer
chacun à ses responsabilités la deuxième
raison c'est que loin de sauver le
régime par répartition en fait on
accélère la précarité parce que
raisonner sur le solage c'est refuser
une autre vision et en particulier
de l'assiette de contribution des
cotisations et du financement de la
retraite et enfin la troisième raison
c'est quand il manquablement on
introduit par là une dimension de
capitalisation et ouvrir la voie à une
retraite
minimale précarisée et de confier le
reste à la capitalisation donc je
plaiderais comme la souligner
jean-Pierre Sueur au début de du débat
quelque chose qui soit plus adapté aux
situations multiples et qui permettent
de répondre à des situations extrêmement
complexes merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur le Président il faut
supprimer l'article 7 car il est en
rupture avec l'évolution sociétale le
président Macron est maintenant élu
depuis 5 ans et demi et devant lui à
l'échec de la réforme systémique il y a
un retour au Paris aux paramétrique un
retour aux paramétrique de la fin du 20e
siècle et c'est un rendez-vous manqué un
rendez-vous manqué paritaire et
parlementaire paritaire car vous avez
réussi l'exploit de mettre tous les
partenaires sociaux pratiquement contre
vous parlementaire car de 49-3 en 47,1
vous avez volontairement réduit le débat
démocratique et réduit une fois de plus
le parlementarisme alors que ce dialogue
induit la capacité de contribuer à
l'apaisement social par son absence vous
contribuez à la désinstitutionnalisation
vous alimentez la colère
en refusant le libre choix de partir à
62 ans même avec une carrière incomplète
vous cassez l'anticipation de sortir
d'un parcours salarial vous cassez le
libre choix que chaque personne peut
avoir à un moment donné et c'est bien
cette rupture à l'évêque l'évolution
sociétale qui pose problème aujourd'hui
et qui crée effectivement du conflit
vous rompez donc ce subtil équilibre et
en repenses aussi petit liquide vous
semblez découvrir la colère qui existait
aujourd'hui dans la rue et qui risque
effectivement de s'amplifier voilà donc
toutes les bonnes raisons aujourd'hui
qui mériteraient de faire en sorte que
cet article 7 soit supprimé car il est à
contresens de l'évolution de la société
monsieur Michaud
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues c'est
amendement propose de supprimer
l'article relatif au recul de l'âge de
départ obligatoire à 60 ans d'ici à 2030
beaucoup de mes collègues ici l'ont
rappelé et l'opposition massive qui
s'exprime d'ailleurs aujourd'hui dans la
rue le confirme cette mesure est injuste
en particulier pour ceux qui exercent
des métiers pénibles qui ont commencé
tôt ou qui ont des carrières hachées les
dispositifs mis en place en parallèle de
cette réforme sont insuffisants pour
combler toutes les failles qu'une telle
disposition entraîne nous considérons
que la mesure dash empêche tout des
basses sereins sur l'avenir de notre
système de retraite elle cristallise les
tensions et les appréhensions des
Français qui plus est un moment donné où
les conditions de vie et la perte de
pouvoir d'achat due à l'inflation sont
source de force inquiétudes pour nos
concitoyens c'est une mesure trop
résultat aller injustes
disproportionnées qui plus est par
rapport aux prévisions de déficit du
système de retraite l'exemple des femmes
et particulièrement parlant le report de
l'âge sera plus marqué pour les femmes
que pour les hommes en effet l'étude
d'impact anticipe un relèvement de l'âge
de départ lié à la réforme de 7 mois
moyenne pour celles-ci contre 5 mois
pour les hommes d'autre part doivent
être étudiés afin de résorber le déficit
sans que les travailleurs les plus
modestes n’est à supporter seuls
l'effort demandé je vous remercie
monsieur Redon sarrazi
la parole
merci monsieur le Président donc c'est
avant de sénateur socialiste écologistes
et républicains vise à ne pas décaler
l'âge légal de la retraite malgré
l'opposition de l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales de salariés et
de la population en témoignent
aujourd'hui l'inédite
intérêt de cette manifestation le
gouvernement sauf si n'a vouloir mener
sa réforme injuste des retraites et
notamment à décaler l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite et augmenter plus
vite que prévu le nombre d'années de
cotisations les sénateurs socialistes
sont profondément opposés à cette
réforme qui n'est ni plus ni moins que
le plus juste des impôts injuste des
impôts sur la vie pour financer les
baisses d'impôts au ménage les plus
riches et aux grandes entreprises cette
réforme va en effet obliger les
travailleurs et les travailleuses de
première ligne à travailler plusieurs
années de plus jusqu'à 64 ans pour ne
pas subir de décote mais parmi les plus
défavorisés un homme sur trois et déjà
mort avant d'atteindre l'âge de 64 ans
le gouvernement veut faire supporter au
seul travailleur le coût de sa réforme
aucune autre piste étudiée il préfère
tuer à la tâche des travailleurs et des
travailleurs aux métiers les plus durs
que de faire payer ces sommes à leurs
employeurs dont il a choisi de faire
baisser les prélèvements de 18 milliards
par an en l'espèce de deux ans
en plus d'être profondément injuste et
inutile cette réforme en se conjuguant à
la réforme de l'assurance chômage qui
réduit la durée d'indemnisation et celle
du RSA va enfin précariser les
travailleurs seniors qui voient leur
durée d'indemnisation chômage réduite et
qui n'auront donc plus que le RSA pour
survivre si bien sûr toutefois ils ont
droit en reculant les gale de deux ans
l'adresse prévoit une hausse cumulée de
5 milliards d'euros des dépenses
sociales 1,3 milliards pour les dépenses
d'assurance chômage et 3,6 pour les
dépenses de prestations sociales qui
peut croire raisonnablement que ce que
propose le gouvernement dans sa réforme
est un quelconque fait amortisseur sur
cette pauvretisation en marche des
travailleurs en particulier nous
combattons donc cette réforme injuste
inutile et efficace monsieur devinez
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre c'est amendement vise bien
évidemment à ne pas décaler l'âge légal
de 62 à 64 ans et à ne pas accélérer la
mise en oeuvre de la réforme Touraine le
mouvement social qui s'oppose au report
de l'âge de départ en retraite à 64 ans
s'inscrit dans une longue liste de
luttes sociales qui ont marqué
l'histoire de la France il a toujours
fallu que les Françaises et les Français
arrachent aux puissants les concessions
qui leur refusaient aujourd'hui le
président de la République veut revenir
sur une de ces conquêtes sociales il
s'attaque à un pilier à un des piliers
de notre modèle social la retraite de
tous les Français en venant deux ans de
vie aux françaises et aux françaises
pour réaliser des économies budgétaires
vous choisissez l'injustice plutôt que
la solidarité vous sacrifiez notre
système de retraite sur l'hôtel du
déficit de l'État pour les seigneurs qui
sont mises en emploi ni en retraite le
recul de l'âge de départ il faudra au
rallongement de leur période de
précarité la part d'inactif non retraité
et de 25 % à 60 ans 71 ans et ces
seigneurs n'ayant ni emploi ni retraite
sont en majorité des femmes en refusant
d'accompagner cette réforme d'une
politique volontariste en matière
d'emplois des seigneurs votre
gouvernement envoie sciemment une partie
d'une classe d'âge dans une trappe à
provoquer sans fin vous vous obstinez à
ne pas abandonner cette réforme injuste
nous nous obstinons à la refuser comment
rester sourd à la mobilisation d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui à l'espoir de tous ceux
pour conclure sont la valeur de notre
pays
je vais conclure non au sacrifice de nos
retraites je chanterelle
merci monsieur le Président nous voici
au cœur de votre réforme la mesure d'âge
qui recule de 62 à 64 ans là je l'égale
de départ à la retraite je tiens à
saluer le courage du sénateur Arnaud et
de plusieurs
parlementaires centrist qui disent tout
haut ce que d'autres à droite pensent
tout bas le critère d'âge est injuste de
toutes les façons de faire une réforme
des retraites c'est la plus injuste qui
soit ce n'est pas moi qui le dit ce
n'est pas uniquement ces quelques
parlementaires centrices qu'ils disent
c'est le président de la République
lui-même qui dans une interview datant
du 26 août 2019 déclarait si on fait une
réforme comme d'habitude comme on fait
depuis 20 ans on dit on va décalage de
départ à la retraite j'ai dit il y a
quelques mois je ne ferai pas ça
pourquoi c'est pas juste de faire ça
parce que quand vous avez commencé à
travailler à 16 ans si je vous décale
votre âge de départ à la retraite alors
même que généralement quand vous avez
commencé la saison vous avez moins de
diplômes vous êtes dans des métiers plus
pénibles c'est profondément injuste
deuxième chose on est dans une économie
où il y a encore beaucoup de chômage il
y a beaucoup de chômage des seniors des
plus âgés si on décale l'âge légal on
dit aux gens restez plus longtemps au
chômage c'est pas correct et non c'est
pas correct parce que c'est une façon de
dire que les femmes et les hommes de ce
pays ne se que des bêtes de somme dont
il faut tirer la plus grande rentabilité
possible
donc comme la majorité des Français nous
nous battrons pour bien évidemment le
retrait de cet article mais pour le
retrait de cette réforme profondément
injuste et brutale
merci monsieur le Président avec cet
amendement nous demandons la suppression
de l'article 7 comme 8 Français sur 10
et les 3 millions et demi de personnes
qui ont défilé aujourd'hui nous nous
opposons à cette réforme et en
particulier le reportage de départ à la
retraite depuis 2017 le gouvernement a
fait le choix de baisser les impôts des
plus riches cela a été rappelé le
déficit actuel ne vient pas d'une
augmentation des dépenses mais d'une
diminution des financements et des
exonérations de cotisation patronales il
est paradoxal d'implorer l'urgence
financière pour justifier votre réforme
et en parallèle de diminuer les impôts
pour les plus riches supprimer la CVAE
mettre en place un flat tax ce choix est
donc un choix politique en reculant
l'âge de départ à la retraite le
gouvernement exclut d'emblée les
solutions alternatives pourquoi ne pas
choisir d'instaurer une surcotisation
sur les plus hauts salaires certains
grands chefs d'entreprises n'y sont pas
opposés et l'ont même proposé il y a
plus de levier plus un levier pour
remédier à de prochain déficits le recul
de l'âge de départ est en état parmi
d'autres et ce n'est pas notre choix
vous faites le choix de l'injustice le
choix de privilégier les plus riche au
mépris d'être travailleuses et des
travailleurs contraints de travailler
deux ans supplémentaires en particulier
les plus précaires vous êtes d'Ali
libéraux pourquoi voulez-vous toucher à
cette liberté de partir dès 62 ans pour
les travailleurs parmi les plus
défavorisés un homme sur trois est déjà
mort avant d'atteindre 64 ans voilà la
réalité de votre réforme Michel Audiard
disait la retraite faut la prendre jeune
faut surtout la prendre vivant c'est pas
les moyens de tout le monde nous ne
voulons pas imposer aux Françaises et en
français qui ont travaillé toute leur
vie et qui aspire à un repos bien mérité
de travailler deux années de plus et
c'est l'objet de mon amour Michael
Valley
merci monsieur le Président l'amendement
que je défends porte sur le même objet
les débats l'assemblés nationales que
nous avons suivies tous avec attention
nous ont permis malgré la violence des
débats de faire parfois mieux
connaissance et d'essayer de comprendre
la façon de fonctionner de Monsieur le
Ministre et comme il commence à se faire
tard et que c'est bien compréhensible
nous sentons l'attention qui s'émoussent
un peu pour essayer de faire passer le
message de notre groupe j'ai trois
questions à l'attention de Monsieur le
Ministre et je demande sa concentration
alors en 10 lettres horizontale
commençant par e synonyme d'obstination
entêtement merci en 7 lettres verticale
finissant également par E se dit d'une
réforme qui toucherait les plus faibles
et épargnerait le capital je pense que
vous l'avez injuste et pour relier les
deux et essayer de faire passer le
message toujours en horizontal aussi en
7 lettres commençant par R et finissant
par T décision qui montrerait que le
gouvernement s'est entendre les millions
de manifestants et renoncerait à
fracturer encore plus le pays retrait je
sais que vous l'aviez car vous êtes
connu pour être meilleur cruciverbiste
que camarade monsieur le ministre donc
c'est une demande de retrait
madame de La Gontrie
merci monsieur le président
tout à l'heure monsieur le ministre du
socle vous avez me semble-t-il pointé le
fait que les réformes des retraites
avaient pu se succéder qu'elles avaient
pu être contestées mais que pour autant
l'opposition d'un moment devenu la
majorité ne les avez pas remises en
cause
et bien je voudrais simplement vous lire
des propos que vous teniez vous-même en
2010 à l'occasion de la réforme des
retraites de 2010 vous disiez la chose
suivante cette volonté de reculer l'âge
de la retraite et doublement injuste
injuste car elle écarte d'emblée la
recherche d'autres recettes tiens tiens
notamment tiens c'est de moi
notamment la mise à contribution de
l'ensemble des revenus et en particulier
ceux du capital
tiens tiens
injuste aussi car elle fera porter les
forces sur des générations aujourd'hui
plus préoccupés par leur situation
actuelle par leur entrée sur le marché
du travail que par la question de la
retraite un de vos collègues qui fut
ministre de la Santé et qui est
désormais porte-parole du gouvernement
vous l'avez
Olivier Véran a dit lui-même mais vous
savez ce gouvernement propose des
réformes de droite et il a choisi pour
les porter des anciens socialistes c'est
vous dire comme notre cœur saigne
Olivier Véran rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales sur
PLFSS 2015
reculez l'âge de la de départ comme le
demande la droite et l'UMP en
particulier
aurait été une option bien injuste et
pour ma part je suis content que le
gouvernement ait fait le choix de porter
cette vitale de ne pas porter cette
vitale évolution avec justice et enfin
votre maître à tous le président de la
République est-ce qu'il faut reculer
l'âge légal qui est aujourd'hui à 62 ans
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas pour
deux raisons la première c'est que je me
suis engagé à ne pas le faire la
deuxième c'est que tant qu'on n'aura pas
réglé le problème du chômage ce serait
hypocrite c'était le 25 avril 2019
monsieur Lauzac
merci monsieur le Président se décalage
de la jungle de départ à la retraite de
62 à 64 ans Béconnais totalement la
perception de la retraite par les
Français ceci perçoivent ce moment de
résistance comme un jus se retour des
choses après des décennies de labeur et
de labeur souvent harassant une
reconnaissance de ce qu'ils ont apporté
la nation durant leur vie
professionnelle or avant même la réforme
qui nous est aujourd'hui proposée selon
une étude récente de la Caisse des
Dépôts c'est 40% de nos concitoyens qui
pensent ne pas avoir de penser au moment
leur départ la retraite et 25%
d'outeraient même de la survie du
système de retraite c'est dire comment
de concitoyens perçoivent notre système
combien ils s'en sentent eux-mêmes
éloignés de par sa complexité et son
injustice or cette réforme n'est pas de
nature à les rassurer bien au contraire
les Français perçoivent que s'éloignent
d'eux une retraite bienvenue dans ces
conditions et son financement car les
choix retenus ne sont pas bons
aujourd'hui l'article 7 symbolise ses
choix justifier un par des raisons
budgétaires comme si des possibilités
alternatives de recettes n'existaient
pas la contestation d'une force sans
précédent de ce report de l'âge de la
retraite rejoint le rejet du sens que
certains donne au travail aujourd'hui à
savoir le culte de la performance et du
rendement l'appât du gain de la
spéculation bref un travail perçu comme
de moins en moins épanouissant et
émancipateurs pour nos concitoyens
douleurs impatience pour une période de
retraite la plus sereine et la plus
longue possible c'est cette perspective
que vous retirez des millions de
Français en faisant reposer la totalité
de votre réforme sur l'allongement du
temps de travail quand on a une réforme
rejetée par deux Français sur trois
voire plus c'est bien qu'on touche aux
vivre ensemble à la cohésion sociale du
pays au bien-être collectif c'est ce que
vous ont rappelé ces foules
considérables de manifestants
aujourd'hui je prendrai comme seul
exemple la ville de qui conclure ou 7000
personnes c'est-à-dire plus de la moitié
de la population de cette ville
préfecture était dans la rue ce matin
alors oui retirez votre réforme
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre j'aimerais associer Catherine
qui est là à cette question et victoire
jasmin qui a dû regagner la Guadeloupe
en posant la question si j'ose dire à sa
place monsieur le ministre du soft a
bien voulu dire jeudi dernier vous
comprenez dans les outre-mer vous partez
déjà à peu près à 65 ans cette loi ne
vous dérangera pas je résume sa pensée
mais c'était un peu ça j'aimerais lui
répondre simplement par quelques
chiffres dans les outre-mer l'âge moyen
de départ à la retraite est déjà
beaucoup plus tardif ici entre
64,3 ans à la Réunion 65 ans en Guyane
62,7 ans dans l'Hexagone ce n'est pas
pour le plaisir mais bien sûr pour ne
mais bien pour ne pas partir avec des
pensions trop faibles que ce départ sont
plus tardifs du fait de carrière moins
stable que dans l'Hexagone interruption
de carrière nombreux emplois emploi
informels l'entrée tardive en activité
risque également par le fort taux de
chômage les jeunes en Guadeloupe près
d'un actif sur de plus de 50% des jeunes
de moins de 30 ans de travail pas et la
même chose pour les seniors à partir de
55 ans la difficulté à accumuler le
nombre de trimestres pour une carrière
complète et d'autant plus de majables
face à la plus faible espérance de vie
des populations
ultramarines l'espérance de vie à la
naissance pour les femmes et de
73,9 ans à Mayotte 81 Guyane 83 à la
Réunion compte 85,5 bref
cette loi là fera très très mal dans les
outre-mer et heureusement la commission
des affaires sociales a rectifier les
tensions du ministre qui voulait
supprimer le seuil de récupération sur
succession on a également mis en
extension litière notamment pour les
fonctionnaires des tailles plus
particulièrement pour les militaires et
bien là c'est une méchanceté infligée et
il serait peut-être bon ce que le
président de l'archive
enciation retirer cette mauvaise loi je
dirais excusez-moi
merci monsieur le Président pourquoi
faut-il supprimer cet article 7 pas
parce que la droite est droite et on
peut vous reconnaître une certaine
constance peut-être davantage parce que
Messieurs Macron et du soft disent
aujourd'hui l'inverse de ce qu'il disait
naguère peut-être aussi parce que la
procédure parlementaire a été détournée
et que les choix qui ont présidé à ce
véhicule législatif
font douter de la qualité du travail que
nous conduisons ensemble la forme c'est
le fond qui remonte à la surface si on
croit si on en croit la forme qui a été
retenue c'est que le fond n'est pas bon
davantage encore il faut supprimer cette
article 7 à cause de l'unité syndicale
que vous avez su réaliser dans la rue la
concertation a été manquée nous ne
voulons pas cautionner l'injustice et la
brutalité de deux ans de travail
supplémentaires à une population qui
n'en veut pas et qui n'en peut plus il
faut supprimer l'article 7 parce qu'il
catalyse
les angoisses toutes les peurs et toutes
les colères il faut surtout supprimer
l'article 7 parce que vous n'avez pas de
plan B quel est le coût d'après qui
soutient cette réforme personne vous
avez tous été des élus locaux vous savez
ce qui peut passer et ce qui peut ne pas
passer ce qui peut être acceptable et ce
qu'il n'est pas il n'y a pas de plan B
et je voudrais vous renvoyer à ce que me
disait certains syndicalistes on a peur
on a peur que ça tourne mal parce que
250 000 gilets jaunes qui ont tout cassé
ont réussi à arrêter les réformes et
quand il y a plusieurs millions de
salariés dans la rue on continue que
faut-il faire alors tout casser pas la
c'est ça la réalité ce n'est pas le bon
moment ce n'est pas la bonne méthode il
y a une population qui est dans
l'inquiétude face à l'inflation face aux
difficultés du quotidien face à un
profond doute démocratique il n'est pas
trop tard pour renoncer à ce mauvais
article 7 il n'est pas trop tard pour
renoncer à cette mauvaise réforme
en avoir
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet article
7 prévoit le report de deux ans de l'âge
légal d'ouverture des droits à la
retraite et cela pour tous les salariés
quel que soit leur difficulté la durée
de leur carrière mais il prévoit aussi
l'accélération de l'augmentation de la
durée des cotisations de la loi Touraine
ces deux dispositifs vont augmenter les
inégalités pour les plus précaires les
femmes ce qui exercent des médias
difficiles cet article 7 comporte les
dispositions les plus régressives de ce
projet de loi ce conjuguant à la réforme
de l'assurance chômage qui réduit la
durée d'indemnisation et à celle du RSA
cette réforme va précariser les
travailleurs seniors qui voient leur
durée d'indemnisation chômage réduite de
8 mois et n'auront donc plus que le RSA
poursuivre s'ils ont droit qui peut
croire raisonnablement que ce que vous
proposez c'est à dire un nouvel
indicateur que devront publier les
entreprises sans aucune obligation de
résultat est une quelconque est un
quelconque effet d'amortisseur sur cette
paupérisation des travailleurs seniors
de plus vous n'avez absolument pas
mesuré les coussins supplémentaires où
nous nous le savons pas induit par cette
réforme sur l'assurance chômage sur le
RSA sur l'assurance même l'a dit cette
réforme est injuste elle est aussi sans
aucune mesure par rapport aux prévisions
du corps sur le déficit du régime de
retraite et au contraire va au contraire
augmenter certaines dépenses publiques
nous vous l'avons déjà dit c'est pour ça
que cet amendement vise à supprimer cet
article 7 monsieur le ministre je pense
que vous n'avez pas d'autre choix que de
retirer cette loi injuste
inutile et inefficace vous devez laisser
le choix aux Français de partir à l'âge
de 62 ans ou de continuer une activité
professionnelle s'il le souhaite
merci monsieur le Président
rendez-vous pas la grande qui partout en
France d'Abbeville à Montauban de
Marseille à Péronne vous en juin à ne
pas décaler l'âge légal de 62 à 64 après
avoir méprisé le dialogue social après
avoir
ignoré les unes après les autres les
revendications des travailleurs après
avoir piétiné le Parlement vous apprêtez
à prendre les deux plus belles années de
la vie de celles et ceux qui l'ont passé
à travailler et qui méritent le repos
et tout ça pourquoi pour équilibrer les
comptes publics asséchés par votre
politique intensive des cadeaux fiscaux
au grandes entreprises avec notamment la
fin de la CVAE et au ménage de les plus
riches en particulier la suppression de
l'ISF et la création de la factase alors
chez moi dans la Somme grâce à vous
l'entreprise Amazon à Bove un milliard
de chiffre d'affaires ne paiera plus de
contribution de 140 000 euros à mieux
métropole par an alors oui vous me direz
c'est une coude d'eau qui est trois fois
rien
mais en période de sécheresse on a
besoin d'un ruissellement justement qui
arrose les plus fragiles
mais les gouttes d'eau font les grandes
rivières et vous le savez la suppression
de la CVE c'est 20 milliards d'euros par
an en moins pour l'État que vous vous
entendez compenser en taxant le 2 années
supplémentaires pour les Français en les
faisant travailler drôles de
ruissellement n'est-ce pas à l'époque où
il n'y a plus d'argent magique
il est grand temps de ne plus offrir un
pognon dingue à ceux qui n'ont pas
besoin enfin je me tourne à la droite de
l'hémicycle et leur offrir une petite
citation
Émile Émile Zola nous prévenait il y a
déjà un siècle l'injustice sociale sème
la haine éternelle et récolte
l'universel souffrance voilà en quelques
mots ce que seront les fruits de cette
réforme injuste et inutile dont vous
vous faites complices éco-auteur
majorité présidentielle et majorité
sénatoriales même combat ne faites pas
davantage souffrir les Français entendez
leur souffrance de notre relation et
retirer cet article
sur le président rénal
comme on a plusieurs plusieurs prises de
parole de cette soirée qui va nous
passionner tous
je vais quand même répondre quelquefois
à ceux qui sur les bancs de la majorité
ce sont exprimés et à ceux qui ont pris
position évidemment pour la réforme
alors notre collègue Cadic par exemple
sénateur des Français
établis hors de France
bien sûr c'était normal dans sa fonction
c'est amusé évidemment à faire une
petite comparaison européenne un peu
mondiale aussi mais mondialement c'est
plus compliqué alors on va faire
européen et donc il nous a dit que la
France avec ses 62 ans semble en effet
faire figure d'exception finalement face
à l'Espagne à l'Allemagne au Pays-Bas ou
à l'Italie mais finalement est-ce que
cette comparaison qui a la route alors
on a une réponse je vais convoquer
évidemment un directeur de recherche du
CNRS qui a travaillé sur ces questions
Bruno pallier et il nous rappelle une
fois tout simple c'est que l'histoire
des deux âges de départ n'est que une
question française et qu'ailleurs en
Europe il n'y a pas deux âges de départ
il y a un nombre de trimestres de
cotisation et des droits qui sont liés à
cela et donc je voudrais vous le dire
très simplement
vous avez effectivement deux âges de
départ et dans la plupart des autres
pays c'est deux âges n'existent pas dès
lors dit ce directeur qui connaît juste
un peu la question il dit les
comparaisons sont totalement biaisées
d'ailleurs sans même bouger l'âge on
arriverait alors ça c'est le corps qui
le dit qu'on arriverait finalement assez
rapidement vers 64 ans de départ en
retraite sauf que avec on a la liberté
de prendre avant si on le souhaite la
retraite avec une décote et bien c'est
cette liberté monsieur Cadix vous qui
est un libéral vous devriez défendre
cette notion de flippe
maintenant monsieur Tissot
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai bien
entendu Olivier Véran nous alerter sur
le risque d'une catastrophe écologique
agricole et sanitaire que nous ferait
courir la mobilisation massive contre
cette réforme de retraite il y a en
effet bien des urgences qui devrait nous
occuper aujourd'hui l'urgence en premier
écologique n'est plus à démontré mais ce
gouvernement qui a été condamné deux
fois pour une action climatique n'a pas
attendu le mot d'ordre de
l'intersyndical pour se mettre à l'arrêt
sur le sujet l'urgence sociale est bien
là aussi et ce n'est pas le projet de
loi indigence le pouvoir d'achat votez
l'été dernier qui aura répondu et dans
ce contexte de forte inflexion les
Français préfèrent en effet que le
gouvernement s'occupe enfin de leur
pouvoir d'achat certes cet article 7 va
impacter le pouvoir d'achat mais dans le
sens d'une baisse des pensions pour les
personnes qui subiront une augmentation
de la décote et auront un effet un héros
pardon et à auront un coefficient
proratisation moins favorable sur le
plan sanitaire l'urgence serait de
répondre enfin la crise profonde que
traverse notre système de santé entre
désertification médicale et effondrement
de l'hôpital public hier monsieur le
rapporteur Savary nous renvoya la
réforme Touraine il s'est bien gardé de
nous parler de Roselyne Bachelot qui en
2010 a fait passer l'âge de l'âge de
départ des infirmières du public de 55 à
62 ans 7 ans travaillant en plus auquel
c'est très fort va venir ajouter deux
années supplémentaires soit 9 ans de
travail en plus rajouter en l'espace de
13 ans on est un peu au-delà de
l'accompagnement de l'allongement de
l'espérance de vie il me semble-t-il
d'ailleurs celui-ci ne progresse plus
depuis 2014 et pendant ce temps la
charge en soins n'a fait qu'augmenter
les soignants sont très souvent épuisés
tant physiquement comme moralement
bien avant la fin de leur carrière cela
pousse nombre d'entre eux à quitter
l'hôpital entraînant des vacances de
poste et de fortes difficultés à
recruter pensez-vous que vous redonnerez
ainsi de l'attractivité au métier du
soin et de l'accompagnement donc
effectivement non seulement cet article
7 ne répond pas assez différentes
urgences mais je pense même qu'il va
plutôt en aggraver certaines aussi avec
cet amendement je vous propose de faire
oeuvre d'efficacité en supprimant tout
simplement cet article 7 madame Lubin
moi j'ai une question
jusqu'à quel âge pensez-vous que les
Français du moins un certain nombre
d'entre eux peuvent travailler
vous croisez tous les jours
tout un tas de personnes qui font des
métiers différents
les femmes de chambre dans les hôtels
les infirmiers les aides-soignantes dans
les hôpitaux les gens que vous voyez en
train de réparer les routes tout ça vous
savez bien vous le savez bien qu'au-delà
de aller 60 ans ça devient compliqué
tout le monde le sait quand même et donc
et donc
[Musique]
si vraiment la situation parce que pour
l'instant je rappelle quand même que au
moment où on se parle là il y a pas de
déficit
des régimes de retraite si vraiment la
situation
devait empirer la situation financière
devait se compliquer terriblement est-ce
que vous pensez que indéfiniment on
pourra retarder l'âge de la retraite non
mais moi je vous pose une question c'est
quel modèle de société que vous voulez
alors vous vous moquez beaucoup de nous
là je vois si si si si je vois que bon
voilà vous n'avez pas à porter grand
chose au débat jusqu'à maintenant les
uns et les autres par contre et vous
êtes resté très silencieux par contre là
ce soir on sent que vous voulez acheter
et que pour vous payer notre tête vous
êtes là bon bref passons nous nous avons
apporté nous avons essayé d'apporter
parce que on pour comme on ne pourra pas
indéfiniment demander aux gens du moins
à certains de travailler plus nous avons
essayé d'apporter des idées parce que
oui à un moment si nous voulons
conserver notre modèle de retraite par
répartition il faudra bien trouver
d'autres moyens il faudra bien élargir
l'assiette des cotisations il faudra
bien trouver d'autres solutions voilà et
donc bon quel modèle de société
voulez-vous nous au moins nous aimerions
y travailler c'est tout
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues alors
oui là nous sommes au coeur de cette
bataille pour le temps de vivre je
pourrais continuer à insister sur le
caractère unique de ce texte et vous
dire que effectivement et nous l'avons
tous dit cette présente très forte et
purement financière mais je préfère
exprimer ce qu'il finalement il aurait
pu être si vous aviez fait les choses
dans le bon ordre c'est-à-dire une
grande réflexion sur le travail et
ensuite un projet de loi sur les
retraites parce que finalement une
réflexion sur le travail dont la
retraite n'est que l'aboutissement nous
aurait permis de montrer que les
évolutions qui traversent le monde de
travail aujourd'hui sont très nombreuses
le véhicule législatif que vous avez
choisi ne nous le permet pas et c'est
très dommage en tout cas il faudra
arrêter et il faut arrêter de feindre
que la valeur du travail est uniforme
identique pour toutes et tous car dans
certains cas oui le travail peut être
synonyme de souffrance et d'aliénation
et dans d'autres cas de bien-être et de
reconnaissance mais les Français ne sont
pas les flemmards comme j'ai pu entendre
il suffit de regarder leur productivité
en revanche il y a une profonde
lassitude qui se nourrit à mon sens de
deux mots majeurs un avenir qui apparaît
de plus en plus incertain et une perte
de sens globale et sur ce point
l'exigence de jeunes générations ne
témoignent que d'une seule chose une
conscience aiguisée des défis et des
enjeux qui nous attendent pour beaucoup
ils ne veulent plus reproduire un modèle
qui ne leur convient plus et surtout qui
n'est pas soutenable alors on aurait pu
parler expérimentation organisation des
carrières correction des inégalités
votre réforme monsieur le ministre est
en tout cas une réforme désuète
déconnectée et elle n'est surtout pas à
la hauteur des enjeux de notre siècle
merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement vous vous en doutez du groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
visent à ne pas décaler là je les garde
62 à 64 ans
monsieur le ministre la mobilisation
massive aujourd'hui vous oblige entendez
la colère des Français qui ne veulent
pas de cette réforme vous faites des
cadeaux fiscaux plus riches et dans le
même temps vous créez un nouvel impôt
sur la vie des plus modestes le repas le
report de deux ans de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite et
inutile et injuste
tout le monde n'a pas la chance d'avoir
un travail passionnant enrichissant
valorisant ce report est un nouvel
exemple de l'acharnement doctrinal d'un
exécutif qui ne peut s'empêcher de
détruire les acquis sociaux monsieur le
ministre malgré vos interventions
répétées dans les médias les Français ne
sont pas dupe les perdants se réforme
sont des millions et sont ces femmes et
ces hommes qui défilent dans les rues
ils sont celles et ceux qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie qui se sont
levés tôt qui ont exercé des métiers
pénibles qui ont commencé toi qui n'ont
pas eu pour certains la chance de faire
des études ils sont celles et ceux qui
sont pourtant si utiles à la France mais
que vous pénalisez sans raison valable
monsieur le ministre il semble que de
vos engagements passés ne reste que des
miettes avec ce réforme vous renoncez à
l'humanisme avec cette réforme vous
enterrer toute idée de progrès social
avec cette réforme le gouvernement
révèle s'il fallait son vrai visage un
visage familier puisqu'il s'agit de
l'ultralibéralisme et de la politique
des plus aisées le silence complice de
la majorité sénatoriale en atteste c'est
main dans la main que l'exécutif et la
droite sénatoriale s'apprête à porter un
coup violent notre système de retraite
monsieur le ministre écoutez les
Français retirer cette réforme sur moto
G
pardon monsieur
le Président chers collègues monsieur le
ministre nous nous opposons au décalage
de l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans et nous ne
se sent pas que la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme Touraine soit accélérée malgré
les messages que vous font passer toutes
les organisations syndicales de salariés
et plus de 8 Français sur 10 plus encore
aujourd'hui vous estimez à vouloir mener
cette réforme injuste qui est de fait un
impôt sur la vie alors que notre système
de retraite n'est pas menacé à long
terme et qu'il doit simplement faire
face aux conséquences du papy boom dans
les décennies 2030 à 2050 d'autres choix
sont possibles et pourtant vous refusez
d'envisager une légère augmentation des
cotisations patronales il suffirait
pourtant de 4 heures euro au niveau du
SMIC et de 28 euros au niveau du salaire
moyen pour combler le déséquilibre
temporaire vous auriez même pu et vous
auriez dû vous contenter d'une
surcotisation sur les plus hauts
salaires et puis en plus d'être
profondément injuste et inutile cette
réforme se conjuguant à la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui réduit la durée
d'indemnisation et à celle du RSA enfin
précariser davantage les travailleurs
seniors qui voient leur durée
d'indemnisation chômage réduite de 8
mois et le RSA en seule perspective pour
survivre Sylvie hongrois le nouvel
indicateur que devront publier les
entreprises sans aucune obligation
d'objectif ou de contrepartie de
résultats n'aura aucun effet amortisseur
sur cette paupérisation en marche des
travailleurs seniors pour toutes ces
raisons et bien d'autres retirez cette
réforme inique les Français vous en
seront gras
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comment
demander à travailler plus longtemps
alors que vous n'avez pas vraiment
commencé à regarder les problèmes de
pénibilité et que même vous avez
supprimé des critères de pénibilité
d'autre part plus d'un tiers des
retraités vise sous le seuil de pauvreté
après une vie de travail la réforme ne
viendra pas corriger cette injustice
sociale mais au contraire ajoutera d'y
arriver deux ans plus tard plus abîmé
pour certains parce qu'ayant dû
poursuivre une activité inadaptée à
l'âge de leurs muscles de leurs artères
de leurs articulations de leur cœur il y
aura nombre de perdants et de perdants
quoi que vous en disiez un travailleur
en situation de pénibilité reconnu
partira deux ans plus tard du fait de la
réforme pour un début de carrière à 18
ans et un travail sans interruption
avant la réforme départ à 62 ans après
la réforme 63 ans voilà la réalité je
rajoute qu'en 2010 le report de l'âge
idéal de 60 à 62 ans c'est traduit par
une hausse de cent mille chômeurs vous
jouez vous avez choisi comme seul levier
la mesure d'âge alors que non seulement
il n'y a pas de réel problème
d'équilibre mais que le taux de chômage
des plus de 55 ans et plus que
préoccupant que ceux qui commencent ce
taux seront défavorisés et que les
femmes payeront le prix très élevé de
cette réforme votre réforme est
archaïque ouvrez les yeux le monde
change les Français aspirent à autre
chose les Français rêvent à d'autres
vies la société française bouge elle
brise de transformation souterraine que
vous ne voyez pas vous les désespérez
par votre réforme dans l'impossibilité
de se projeter dans un avenir heureux
avec l'instabilité que vous créez et
nous avons compris lors de l'examen de
cette loi que vous pensiez à une réforme
à une une réforme de retraite par point
c'est pourquoi mon amendement propose la
suppression
si vous passez oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
cet amendement de notre groupe vise à ne
pas décaler l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans
et de ne pas accélérer la mise en oeuvre
de la réforme Touraine monsieur le
ministre avec ce nouvel âge de départ à
la retraite injustifiée les conséquences
sont nombreuses la hausse de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits est un mauvais
paramètre de pilotage du système de de
retraite si votre gouvernement sentait à
appliquer indifféremment à tous les
assurés les personnes ayant commencé à
travailler tôt seront encore une fois
les grands perdants au changent 20 ans
depuis plus de 20 ans notre système de
retraite tant à substituer le critère de
l'âge à celui de la durée d'assurance
requise comme clé de voûte du système
pourtant c'est la durée d'assurance
requise qui permet une meilleure
individualisation des droits selon le
parcours professionnel de mieux cibler
les mécanismes de solidarité notamment
par l'octroi de trimestre inversement le
critère de l'âge d'ouverture des droits
demande de créer des dispositifs
dérogatoires dont le calibrage n'est
jamais satisfaisant le gouvernement veut
imposer un impôt de deux ans sur la vie
des travailleurs des plus précaires et
des plus fragiles une autre réforme de
retraite est possible nous n'avons eu de
cesse de le répéter et c'est ce n'est ni
la manipulation des chiffres présentés
par le corps ni la dissimulation de la
vie qui a rendu le Conseil d'État ni
aucun de vos tours de passe-passe qui
réussiront à duper les Français j'ai eu
l'occasion d'assister à de nombreuses
comédies pourtant aucune née à la
hauteur de celle interprétée par le
président et ses ministres le système de
retraite par répartition n'est pas
menacée et si le gouvernement placé
enfin ses efforts dans la création d'une
société plus juste une société où l'on
ajouterait à l'abondance de ceux qui ont
peu plutôt qu'à celle de ceux qui ont
moins nous avons saurions enfin dans la
bonne direction les Français ne croient
plus à vos mensonges votre réforme n'est
qu'une énième acte
pitoyable comédie merci sur le Custer
merci monsieur le Président dans le
droit fil de ce que vient de dire
monsieur sanzione je constate que avec
cette réforme les personnes qui
atteindront la durée requises pour le
taux plein avant l'âge d'ouverture des
droits devront travailler au-delà du
nombre de trimestres nécessaires sans
pouvoir bénéficier de la surcotte cela
est déjà le cas mais l'âge réel de
départ en retraite du fait de
l'augmentation de la durée de
cotisations et selon les situations si
ce n'est proches déjà au dessus des 62
ans cela sera bien moins le cas avec un
recul de l'âge d'ouverture des droits 64
ans inversement les personnes ayant
commencé à travailler plus tardivement
ayant fait des études longues
bénéficieront davantage de la surcote
puisqu'elles atteindront la durée
requise pour le taux plein après l'âge
légal
depuis plus de 20 ans notre système de
retraite tente à substituer le critère
de l'âge par celui de la durée
d'assurance requise comme clé de voût du
système la durée d'assurance requise
permet une meilleure individualisation
des droits selon les parcours
professionnels et elle permet de mieux
cibler plus facilement de surcroît les
mécanismes de solidarité notamment par
l'octroi de trimestre inversement le
critère de l'âge d'ouverture des droits
demande de créer des dispositifs
dérogatoires dont le calibrage n'est
jamais satisfaisant en un mot
pourquoi choisir la rigidité d'une norme
unique
qui est préjudiciable plutôt que la
souplesse
la possibilité d'adaptation et de prise
en compte de la diversité des situations
que proposerait que permettrait un
système alternatif cœur rouge
président ce ministre comme je suis
sénateur des Landes
je vais me permettre
de citer Henri manueli ça fera plaisir
sur les bords de la droite
Henri Emmanuelli qui en 2010 disait le
problème n'est pas d'une ampleur réelle
qu'il mérite que l'on remette en cause
une conquête sociale majeure
avant de déplacer l'âge de la retraite
il y a beaucoup d'autres possibilités
élargir l'assiette des cotisations entre
autres pourquoi faudrait-il mettre le
pire au départ je remarque que quand il
y a une frise une crise financière on
trouve facilement 20 milliards d'euros
sans problème je ne comprends pas quand
il s'agit de 10 milliards cela
deviendrait une catastrophe nationale
modifier l'âge et le pire c'est le pire
des symboles on ferait mieux de parler
du million de chômeurs qui va sortir de
l'analysation bon pour le million de
chômeurs qui va sortir de l'analysation
monsieur le ministre c'est déjà fait
mais pour le reste pour le reste cette
phrase ne fait que traduire le titre
d'un très beau livre de Dardot et Laval
qui s'appelle la nouvelle raison du
monde et la nouvelle raison du monde on
l'a entendu tout à l'heure sur les bancs
de la droite le néo libéralisme c'est
une rationalité c'est inéluctable on
nous a parlé de la compétition de la
rationalité
et donc cette rationalité néolibérale
elle devient le seul modèle devant
lequel il faut se plier en tout cas le
seul modèle devant lequel vous vous
pliez c'est pour ça que le président
Retailleau nous a fait le discours
habituel de la responsabilité et du
sacrifice et dans ce cas de la
responsabilité et du sacrifice les gens
ne comptent plus ils ne sont plus que
des instruments et c'est ça qui vous
dérange quand on cite telle ou tel les
Français ne vous intéressent pas prier
individuellement ils deviennent des
chiffres des chiffres qui ne sont pas
importants peu importe que à l'âge de la
retraite 25% des plus pauvres soient
déjà morts
plus rien ne compte il n'y a plus que
des cons il faut conclure et bien je dis
pour faire un clin d'oeil à Michael
Vallet retirer cette réforme injuste mot
qu'on me triple comme au scrabble madame
Monnier
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues donc cet
amendement vise à supprimer l'article 7
du projet de loi qui veut décaler l'âge
légal de la du départ à la retraite de
62 à 64 ans depuis plusieurs semaines
les Françaises et les Français
témoignent avec constance de leur refus
de cette réforme injuste cristallisée
par cet article 7 les organisations
syndicales sont unanimes dans leur
opposition le gouvernement fait pourtant
le choix de rester sourd à ce front
solide et de nier manifestation après
manifestation l'importance de la
mobilisation sociale plus de 3 millions
de personnes dans les rues aujourd'hui
comment pourra-t-on s'étonner après de
la défiance croissante de la population
envers le monde politique et nos
instances démocratiques face à un tel
passage en force je comprends très bien
pourquoi mes collègues de la majorité
sénatoriale approuvent cet article il
s'inscrit dans la continuité
d'amendement déposé chaque année au
PLFSS nous pouvons le reconnaître cette
constance et leur capacité à reconnaître
une réforme de droite pas du tout de
gauche monsieur le ministre du Travail
mais cette réforme paramétrique
uniquement poussée par une logique
comptable n'était pas le premier choix
du président de la République il avait
en réalité raison de déclarer en 2019
qu'on ne savait plus déjà quoi faire
après 55 ans et qu'il serait hypocrite
de décaler l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite sans avoir d'abord résolu la
question de l'emploi des seniors et non
ce n'est pas l'index senior qui
apportera cette réponse où le CDI Senner
introduit au Sénat nouveau cadeau aux
entreprises au détriment du financement
de notre système de protection sociale
rappelons qu'entre la mi 2010 et 1000
2022 le nombre de bénéficiaires de
l'allocation chômage
âgée d'au moins 60 ans cet accru de 100
000 que selon les derniers chiffres de
l'Insee le taux d'emploi des 60 64 ans
et deux fois plus faible que celui du
reste de la population ce recul bructal
de l'âge légal engendora une hausse du
chômage chez les personnes seniors nous
demandons le retrait de cette article et
de cette loi
madame Carlotti oui merci monsieur le
Président c'est amendement vise donc à
supprimer l'article 7 qui décalage légal
de 62 à 64 ans et augmente plus vite que
prévu le nombre d'années de cotisations
ces dispositions vont provoquer un choc
de précarité pour beaucoup de
travailleurs un des classement social
pour les personnes abîmées par de
longues années passées au travail tout
le monde se répertant et d'abord les
catégories populaires les plus
vulnérables ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 23 ans et ceux qui ont
du mal à se maintenir en emploi après 58
ans mais outre que c'est une réforme
injuste cette réforme est aussi une
aberration économique le report à 64 ans
va générer un surplus de dépenses de
protection sociale notamment un RSA en
pension d'invalidité en indemnités
journalières d'arrêt de travail etc et
sur la base du service statistique du
ministère des affaires sociales c'est
donc pas nous ce surcoût est estimé à
5,4 milliards d'euros par an ce qui
reviendrait donc à annuler une grande
partie des économies que le gouvernement
entendait faire avec cette réforme et
que vous avez estimé à 8 milliards
d'euros pour autant vous avez refusé
toutes les autres sources de financement
que nous proposions pour financer ses
retraites mais il est vrai que sacrilège
ses propositions touchées au revenu
toucher aux dividendes et au profiteurs
de la crise et là vous ne voulez pas
toucher à leur grisby votre réforme est
injuste c'est une aberration économique
et à les rejetée par les Français donc
retirer là
merci monsieur le Président excusez-nous
la retraite avant l'arthrite
métro boulot caveau ne pas passer sa vie
à la gagner quels sont les mots des
manifestants qui depuis le mois de
janvier nous exprime leur inquiétude et
leur rejet de cette réforme ils sont des
centaines de milliers réunir chaque
semaine avec les organisations
syndicales partout en France pour dire
NON nous l'avons encore vu aujourd'hui
et non la pérennité de notre système de
retraite n'est pas en danger le corps
nous l'a encore confirmé dans un rapport
de 2022 cette mesure n'a pour que pour
seul objectif de financer les belles
impôts accordés au plus riche et aux
grandes entreprises il faut bien
financer la baisse de prélèvement de 18
milliards d'euros en deux ans accordée
aux employeurs le gouvernement a donc
fait un choix un impôt sur la vie des
Français pourtant d'autres solutions
pouvaient être envisagées il suffisait
d'augmenter les cotisations de 14 euros
au niveau du déjà été dit et les
Français ont bien dit qu'il
préféreraient une augmentation des
cotisations à un allongement de deux ans
de travail mettre en place une
surcotisation sur les plus haut salaires
rétablir l'ISF taxer les retraites
chapeau les hyper confits les super
dividendes et même tout simplement faire
que le travail des femmes soit payé au
même niveau que celui des hommes tout
cela de tout cela rien ne vous agréer le
gouvernement continue à se cramponner à
son dogme de moins d'impôts pour les
plus riches et donc sacrifie pour cela
les travailleurs et les travailleuses au
métier les plus durs ce sont les plus
précaires et les femmes aux carrières
hachées qui vont payer la note 11
milliards sur 18 milliards d'économies
sont faits sur le dos des femmes nous
n'aurons décès de le répéter cette
réforme est injustifiée injuste et nous
la combattrons jusqu'au bout supprimer
cet article
monsieur Lecomte merci monsieur le
Président mais monsieur les ministres
mes chers collègues
bien entendu quand nous avons un débat
si si passionné depuis quelques jours
bien entendu il y a quelques hyperboles
comme j'entends vous n'avez pas changé
vous avez laissé la réforme de 2010 vous
n'avez rien changé bah si on a mis des
critères de pénibilité en particulier on
a mis d'abord la priorité à un nombre
d'années cotisés et avec des critères de
pénibilité qui ont été retirés par les
gouvernements d'Emmanuel Macron alors
hier nous avons eu un débat sur le
progrès technologique l'augmentation de
la productivité
qui permet l'augment le progrès
technologique qui permet d'augmentation
de la productivité et une évolution une
atténuation de la pénibilité d'un
certain nombre de métiers nous avons
évoqué aussi les nouvelles membres de
travail le télétravail
l'auto-entrepreneur qui nécessite
d'imaginer d'autres moyens d'assurer
adéquatement pour ces fonctions la
solidarité nationale mais allons plus
loin le travail a toujours été l'élément
quasiment structurant de toute société
sédentaire être et ces sociétés ont
toujours eu des forts dynamisme
démographiques or nous devons constater
que les choses changent ce que nous
vivons en termes de démographie en
France beaucoup de sociétés le vivent de
l'Amérique latine au Japon en Europe
centrale en Chine en Corée et nous
devons aussi constater que il y a des
évolutions sociétales la grande
démission la démission silencieuse bref
de nouveau rapport au travail dans cette
société qui atténue son dynamisme
démographique sont aussi constatés ce
sont des fêtes et pourtant
cette réforme elle ne prend pas en
compte ce nouveau rapport au travail
cette nouvelle situation monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président parce que
votre réforme s'avère être un médicament
périmé sur un diagnostic faux nous
proposons la suppression de l'article 7
selon la profession selon les selon la
profession qu'ils exercent c'est la
pénabilité de leur trace vers deux plus
belles dornées de retraite pourraient
ainsi se transformer en deux années
demandées difficiles au travail aussi il
est important de rappeler que la
Direction de la recherche des études et
d'évaluation des statistiques
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé est
aujourd'hui de 67 ans pour les femmes
65,6 pour les hommes je crois que les
Français ont bien compris l'enjeu de
cette réforme on constate d'ailleurs que
les efforts de pédagogie mis en oeuvre
par le gouvernement n'ont fait que
renforcer leur opposition à cet article
7 et au recul de l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite ils ont compris que les
logiques budgétaires qui vivent de cette
réforme repose au moins autant sur la
diminution de la durée du temps de
travail passé à la retraite que sur la
durée de l'augmentation des cotisations
cet amendement je vous propose donc tout
simplement de le supprimer
oui monsieur le Président ils étaient
75000 à Nantes 17000 à Saint-Nazaire
8000 à Châteaubriand 4000 à Ancenis j'ai
pas vraiment les chiffres de Clisson
mais ils étaient nombreux devant la gare
la Loire-Atlantique était mobilisée
contre le report de l'âge légal à la
retraite à 64 ans je voudrais faire
valoir ici les arguments avancés par les
représentants et les représentants du
secteur du handicap ce secteur a exprimé
sa forte opposition à la réforme au
travers d'une tribune réunissant 52
associations organisation du collectif
handicap voici ce qu'elles exprimaient
début février je les cite avec des taux
de chômage et de pauvreté largement
supérieures à la moyenne nationale une
fatigue habilité importante et des
carrières en d'Annecy les personnes en
situation de handicap sont fortement
pénalisés
de la retraite selon l'adresse en
moyenne les personnes en situation de
handicap reste 8 années et demi sans
emploi ni retraite après 50 ans contre
une année et huit mois pour les
personnes sans incapacité avec cette
réforme ces situations sans emploi ni
retraite vont se multiplier la précarité
va progresser pour ces métiers du
sanitaire et du social précisément dans
l'accompagnement au quotidien des
personnes en situation de handicap le
report va encore plus dégradé leur état
de santé déjà bien fragile avant l'âge
de la retraite qui va payer l'addition
l'assurance chômage la branche accident
du travail ce secteur subit déjà une
crise de recrutement sans précédent que
votre gouvernement renonce à prendre en
compte de façon ambitieuse par une loi
grand âge et autonomie qui fixeraient
comme objectif des soins et de
l'attention à hauteur de la dignité des
personnes accompagnées
merci me le Président je veux pas être
long parce que je crois que il y aura
plus aucun argument qui convaincra qui
que ce soit de toute façon mais je
voudrais faire suite merci pour ces
applaudissements nourris faudrait faire
suite à l'intervention du président
Retailleau et à celle que j'ai fait tout
à l'heure pour exprimer mes craintes sur
les suites politiques de cette réforme
je voudrais rappeler à Bruno Retailleau
que certes en 2010 vous avez fait passer
un pas premier
recul de deux ans de l'âge légal mais
qu'en 2011 vous avez perdu les élections
sénatoriales en 2012 vous avez perdu la
présidentielle et vous n'êtes jamais
revenu au pouvoir depuis et on sait ce
que sont ces conséquences là ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que c'est que de
se réforme oui mais faire ça il y a des
conséquences politiques derrière et que
cette fois-ci les conséquences
politiques elles ne se situeront pas
nécessairement dans l'arc républicain et
vous le savez et vous le savez c'est
tout le problème c'est que là
l'exploitation politique des
conséquences de cette réforme c'est
d'autres qui sont aux aguets et vous
l'entendez dans vos départements vous
l'entendez dans vos villes alors quel
que soit
la justesse que vous estimez de celle de
cette réforme et j'entends je connais
votre raisonnement encore une fois
depuis longtemps et je le respecte et
vous le savez mais les conséquences
elles les dépassent largement et cette
fois-ci cette fois-ci je crains ce qui
va se passer derrière je crains ce qui
se passe dans notre pays vous pour
reprendre l'expression qu'a tenu
aujourd'hui un ancien Premier ministre
maître de l'attention dans un pays en
implosion est un risque sérieux voilà
donc il faut être raisonnable il faut
retirer cette réforme président kener
merci Monsieur Président Monsieur
féministe
je viens d'entendre notre collègue
Bernard jumier pour une fois je serai un
petit peu en décalage avec son analyse
ça peut arriver c'est rare mais ça peut
arriver puisque finalement
il vous mobilise dans une minorité mais
vous n'êtes plus vraiment minoritaire
vous êtes dans une coalition
et le chef de la Coalition s'appelle
Emmanuel Macron mais ça vous avez du mal
à le reconnaître manifestement alors mes
chers collègues puisque je parle du
président de la République
le nouveau monde ça vous dit
c'était il y a 70 mois
70 mois de d'Emmanuel Macron à la tête
de l'État et ce nouveau monde vient de
produire un projet de loi
qui est probablement le plus grégressif
depuis la loi Fillon de 2010 et surtout
ce qui est absolument insupportable
monsieur les ministres c'est que vous
voulez faire payer le désarmement fiscal
du pays à nos concitoyens
majoritairement frapper déjà par les
phénomènes de l'inflation et vous
considérez de manière cynique c'est à
eux de payer pour ce désarmement fiscal
et bien nous vous disons NON depuis six
jours nous considérons que ce n'est pas
la solution et que quand on vous dit non
ce n'est pas uniquement sur les quelques
bancs de gauche ici dans l'hémicycle de
la Haute Assemblée ce sont ces millions
de Français qui sont descendus dans la
rue et ces millions de Français qui
soutiennent toutes celles et tous ceux
qui sont descendus dans la rue alors mes
chers collègues bien vous avez compris
que à l'instar de ce que on dit les
autres collègues ici présents ils nous
demandons la suppression de l'article 7
je suis Assouline
oui pour prolonger avec mes collègues
cette entêtement me rappelle quelque
chose et devrait d'ailleurs rappeler
quelque chose à quelques sénateurs ici
et notamment au premier d'entre eux qui
nous préside aujourd'hui dans cette
séance le président Larcher
souvenez-vous ce débat sur la loi
égalité des chances avec ce CPE qui
était niché dans cette loi et qui nous
avait occupé jour et nuit dans une
bagarre mémorable dans cette hémicycle
je me souviens que il y avait beaucoup
de monde dans la rue et que
manifestation après manifestation on
voyait bien que ça ne désemplissait pas
et que malgré les débats ici ou tous les
arguments étaient avancés sur le fait
qu'en réalité c'était pour sauver la
jeunesse et que la jeunesse ne
comprenait pas et se mobiliser toujours
plus massivement qu'on se CPE
souvenez-vous vous avez été
humilié de faire ce travail parce que
souvenez-vous que vous n'avez pas écouté
la rue vous êtes mis en difficulté par
rapport aux jeunes et par rapport à vos
propres électeurs mais à la fin cette
loi a été votée
mais le président Chirac il ne l'a pas
appliqué
j'ai peur enfin pour vous qu'on puisse
être dans un scénario comme celui-là sur
la loi sur les retraites parce que si le
pays continue à se mobiliser comme il se
mobilise
ce sera intenable et c'est nous qui
devons être ce qui a l'air parce que
c'est nous qui avons le lien avec les
citoyens c'est vous qui retournez dans
vos circonscriptions et c'est vous qui
avez des comptes à rendre à tous ceux
qui sont parmi vos électeurs et qui sont
contre donc vous pouvez mesurer l'écart
qu'il y a entre ce que vous faites ici
pour le bien des citoyens et comment ils
le reçoivent et à la fin ça se finit
toujours mal en tous les cas j'espère
que vous même vous battrait cette
réforme et vous votre compte
monsieur manier
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement vise à ne pas décaler l'âge
légal de 62 64 ans et ne pas accéder ne
pas accélérer la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme Touraine la réforme proposée par
le gouvernement apparaît effectivement
injuste et particulièrement parce que là
je l'égal de départ de la retraite
serait décalé et que le nombre d'années
de cotisations
vous le disent ils sont profondément
opposés à cette réforme qui n'est ni
plus ni moins que le plus injuste des
impôts sur la vie notre système de
retraite n'est pas menacé à long terme
il doit simplement faire face aux
conséquences momentanées du papy boom
dans les décennies 2030 à 2050 et
d'autres choix sont possibles ils ont
été longuement exposés ici depuis le
début de nos débats
de plus en se conjuguant à la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui réduit la durée
de l'indemnisation et à celle du RSA
cette réforme va précariser les
travailleurs seniors qui voient leur
durée d'indemnisation chômage réduite de
8 mois et non donc plus que le RSA pour
vivre si bien sûr ici en droit qui peut
croire raisonnablement que ce que
propose du gouvernement dans sa réforme
est un quelconque qui est fait
amortisseur sur cette paupérisation en
marche des travailleurs seniors ce
projet de loi de régression sociale
apparaît inacceptable c'est une réforme
injuste
inutile et inefficacité donc ici de
supprimer l'article de ce projet
même la présidente Rossignol merci
monsieur le Président j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure l'intersyndicale
non pas que je veux absolument mettre ça
porte-parole dans cette hémicycle mais
pour connaître le mouvement social le
mouvement syndical depuis de nombreuses
années je sais mesurer ce que signifie
un mouvement syndical uni dans un moment
comme celui qu'on vit et je sais aussi
ce que signifie la mobilisation de 1
million 500 000 à 3 millions de
personnes contre une réforme
l'intersyndicale s'est réunit ce soir
elle a donné ses nouvelles
préconisations je vais vous les lire
je pense que c'est pas inintéressant
pour vous non plus même si vous les
soutenez pas c'est toujours bien de
savoir ce que font les autres le 16
février face à l'absence de réponse du
gouvernement l'Inter syndicale amené
appeler à mettre la France à la reine 7
mars c'est une journée historique par
l'ampleur de ses grèves et de ses
mobilisation à ce jour ces mobilisations
énormes conduites par une interse
syndicaturite unie non reçu aucune
réponse de la part du gouvernement cela
ne peut plus durer le silence du
président de la République constitue un
problème démocratique grave qui conduit
un manquablement à une situation qui
pourrait devenir explosive en
responsabilité l’inter syndicale c'est
très au président de la République
l'intersyndicale appelle à une nouvelle
mobilisation interprofessionnelle ce
samedi 11 mars puis la semaine prochaine
à une manifestation le jour de la
commission mix paritaire elle appelle la
population a continué à l'obligation et
les actions encore plus massivement pour
dire non à cette réforme injuste et
brutale
voyez-vous
cette inter syndicale elle prend à la
fois la responsabilité de continuer
d'accompagner le mouvement social et
nous nous devons être à la hauteur de
cette responsabilité monsieur le
ministre vous ne pouvez pas continuer de
ne pas répondre au mouvement social et à
l'Inter syndical et nous chers collègues
en votant nos amendements de suppression
de l'article 7 nous permettrions à tout
le monde de sortir la tête haute de
cette affaire madame la Présidente
oui mais merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues mesdames Messieurs
les messieurs encore les membres du
gouvernement je crois qu'il n'y a aucune
mais vraiment strictement aucune donnée
chiffrée qui permet de justifier que
l'allongement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans ainsi que
l'allongement des trimestres de
cotisation et nécessaire nous en avons
déjà fait la démonstration lors de nos
précédents débats je crois que nous
sommes assez offensif et nous
continuerons donc à dire et à proposer
que des économies et enfin à dire que
des économies peuvent être réalisés
ailleurs sans porter atteinte au régime
actuel de retraite selon l'institut
national d'étude démographique
l'espérance de vie doit aussi être
appréciée en tenant compte de l'âge
auquel il y a un vrai risque
d'incapacité dans les gestes de la vie
quotidienne ce concept rejoint en
quelque sorte celui de l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé que nous défendons et
bien chers collègues cette espérance de
vie prenant en compte l'incapacité à
effectuer les gestes de la vie
quotidienne se situent en France à
64,1 an pour les femmes et
62,7 ans pour les hommes la réforme donc
actuelle qui nous est proposée par le
gouvernement avec la complicité de la
droite sénatoriale aggrave le risque de
liquider les pensions de retraite à un
âge où le retraité n'est plus ou la
retraité et plus en mesure de profiter
comme il ou elle le souhaiterait du
fruit de son labeur nous maintenons donc
que votre projet celui de la destruction
sociale et après ce que ce qui vient
d'être vient d'être dit par Madame
Rossignol je le répète il faudrait
peut-être que vous entendiez à la fois
ce qui s'est dit exprimé aujourd'hui
dans les rues des villes et qu'elles
soient petites moyennes ou grande et que
vous écoutiez aussi et que vous sachiez
lire le communiqué le communiqué de la
terre syndicale
merci monsieur le Président avec cette
article 7 il s'agit en effet du recul de
l'âge de la retraite et de
l'accélération de la hausse des durées
de cotisation qui sont censées réduire
ou lutter contre les déficits de notre
système de protection sociale au passage
monsieur le ministre quand vous nous
dites tout à l'heure
que l'âge de départ sans décote sera
maintenu à 67 ans et ne sera pas à 69
ans j'espère que vous n'imaginez pas que
les Français vous remercient largement
parce que vous risquez d'être encore un
peu déçu au passage toujours je trouve
quand même assez inquiétant de constater
que
en fait la politique c'est
identifier des problèmes et il apporter
des réponses et si certains d'entre vous
sont assis à la droite de cette
hémicycle d'autres à la gauche de cette
hémicycle c'est que nous avons des
options différentes pour répondre à des
problématiques que nous pouvons parfois
identifier ensemble or je vois que
beaucoup ici
préféreraient un passage en force qu'un
débat sur des solutions alternatives à
ce report de l'âge de la retraite et les
Français le sentent bien qu'on leur
refuse ce débat c'est ça aussi qu'il
aimait de plus en plus nombreux dans la
rue parce que voilà un débat de société
au sens noble du terme qui pourrait
faire en sorte que nos concitoyens
renouent avec la politique mais vous la
refusez encore une fois certains d'entre
vous préféreraient passer en force et
enfin puisqu'il s'agit de prétendus
déficit j'ai eu l'occasion tout à
l'heure de montrer en quoi le coût
social de ce report de l'âge allait être
très conséquent sur la vie associative
démocratique dans nos communes etc je
pense qu'il leur sera aussi en termes de
pure des pensées sociales par
l'augmentation des arrêts de travail par
la baisse du niveau de pension qui va
faire en sorte que de nouvelles dépenses
sociales vont devoir être déployées pour
empêcher que des retraités dans la
pauvreté et donc je crois qu'il n'est
absolument pas question d'économie avec
ce projet
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues l'espérance
de vie en bonne santé de 64 ans pour les
femmes 62,7 pour les hommes reculez
l'âge de départ à 64 ans et donc il
n'acceptable pour la moitié des salariés
vous nous répondez c'est pas le sujet le
taux d'emploi des seniors est de 35%.
donc allongez la durée créera des
retraités pauvres vous nous dites c'est
pas le sujet on vous a proposé de
financer autrement t'accélérer riche non
les dividendes sûrement pas élargir
l'assiette pas possible gagner la
bataille de l'emploi attendez la loi
travail l'égalité salariale c'est la
grande cause du quinquennat vous allez
voir taxer la rente sûrement pas vous
allez tuer le ruissellement on vous a
dit vous avez une question démocratique
vous êtes minoritaire 3,5 millions de
travailleurs et de travailleuses dans la
rue vous avez assumé monsieur le
ministre on assume d'être impopulaire et
donc pour vous une seule solution deux
ans de plus deux ans qui vont peser sur
les classes populaires les essentielles
les celles et ceux qui ont tenu le pays
à bout de bras pendant le covid ceux qui
ont des cari arrachés les horaires
décalés ceux qui triment et que le
travail concasse le cœur et les esprits
mais vous vous nous parlez justice
travailler
alors que pour nous il faudrait partager
partager le travail le savoir et les
richesses enfin si vous n'êtes pas
convaincu un dernier
argument est-ce que vous pensez
sincèrement que c'est le moment même
Olivier Véran l'a dit
occupons-nous d'abord de l'inflation du
prix de l'électricité des salaires de
l'emploi de la formation et de la
réindustrialisation du pays avant de
voler les deux plus belles années des
retraites seul le ministre il est temps
de battre en retraite et de retirer
votre projet de loi
[Musique]
tu Laurent
oui merci monsieur le Président tout à
l'heure le président Retailleau nous a
dit quelque chose qui était faux
il nous a dit depuis 40 ans personne
n'est revenu sur une réforme des
retraites qui avait été votée c'est faux
en 1980 il y a 40 ans la gauche a voté
une réforme historique qui a passé l'âge
de départ à la retraite de 65 ans à 60
ans c'était une des réformes qui ont
marqué le siècle oui qui ont marqué un
siècle de progrès sociaux comme les
congés payés à une certaine époque comme
la réduction de la journée du temps de
travail à d'autres etc donc il y a eu un
progrès historique et la vérité c'est
qu'en fait vous ne l'avez jamais accepté
donc ensuite on a eu le droit à Balladur
en 93 à Fillon en 2003 et Sarkozy en
2010 et les 62 ans c'est déjà vous c'est
vous les 62 ans c'est vous qui avez
institué les 62 ans en 2010 et
aujourd'hui vous voulez passer à 64 ans
et si vous étiez resté au pouvoir si
vous étiez resté au pouvoir sans
discontinuer on discuterait pas 62 ou 64
on serait toujours restés à 65 et on
serait probablement à 67 aujourd'hui
parce que vous auriez rajouté deux ans
comme dodo dans d'autres pays européens
donc en vérité ce projet-là c'est votre
projet depuis toujours et le et ce qu'on
a entendu de la part du rapporteur
Savary qui s'éclipse au moment où je
parle de lui c'est une fable c'est une
fable l'idée
l'idée
l'idée que vous êtes finalement obligé
d'en poser les 64 ans parce qu'on a fait
les 40 parce que toi Marisol Touraine a
fait les 43 nuts c'est de la blague en
vérité depuis 1980 votre rêve c'est de
revenir à 65 ans et aujourd'hui vous
progressez alors effectivement monsieur
Retailleau a raison
c'est une réforme de droite à laquelle
le gouvernement aujourd'hui sera lit
qu'il met en oeuvre que vous allez
soutenir
qu'elle sera combattue par elle ne sera
pas appliquée
chers collègues républicains
vous jouez avec le feu
j'ai bien entendu l'argumentaire de
votre président de groupe monsieur
Retailleau
son argumentaire c'est
nous avons le courage de faire des
réformes un peu populaires
parce que nous savons mieux que le
peuple ce qui est bon pour la nation
alors on le fait une fois
et puis on le fait deux fois et puis on
croit qu'on va pouvoir continuer comme
ça
pendant des lustres pas figurez-vous que
non pour une raison simple c'est que la
première fois les Français ils peuvent y
croire vous allez sauver le système de
répartition vous allez répondre au
problème de du temps et les choses vont
être meilleures pour la nation
et puis il se rendent compte que réforme
après réforme c'est pire pour eux c'est
pire pour le pays donc il ne vous croit
plus
il ne vous croit plus et jamais dans
l'histoire le général de Gaulle aurait
eu comme raisonnement
oui oui
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
chaque fois
chaque fois que le général de Gaulle a
eu un doute
eu un doute sur le soutien des Français
il a été devant le peuple il a fait
référendum vous vous avez peur de faire
cela
[Applaudissements]
elle est conséquente de ces attitudes
elle est
conséquence de ces attitudes
accumuler dans le temps où vous
terrorisez que la bonne politique c'est
celle qui doit être faite contre le
peuple et la même le peuple à s'abstenir
elle amène le peuple à accumuler la
colère et la mène le peuple à se
démoraliser sur l'avenir de la France
elle amène le CUP vers l'extrême droite
merci Monsieur Ouzoulias
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre j'ai posé une
question et j'ai pas eu de réponse donc
vous vous me permettrez de reposer ma
question elle est très simple lors de la
campagne électorale le président de la
République avait expliqué que le recul
de l'âge de 2 ans permettrait de
financer un minimum retraite à 1200
euros pour tout le monde on sait
aujourd'hui que seul si si je peux je
peux vous redonner les propos de
Monsieur Macron on sait maintenant que
seuls 10000 à 20000 retraités pourront
en bénéficier je vous repose donc une
nouvelle fois à la question quel est le
gain budgétaire de cette réforme des
retraites les économistes évaluent à
0,6% du PIB le surcroît de recettes
budgétaire dans 10 ans est-ce que vous
nous confirmez maintenant cette
évaluation et je pense chers collègues
qu'il faudrait prendre conscience comme
l'a dit très bien le président
Retailleau qu'il s'agit aussi d'une
réforme budgétaire c'est un point c'est
très important que les Français sachent
que là on est en train de discuter d'un
nouvel impôt Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur ça vole Delhi
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
lesbiisme mes chers collègues commencez
par ça vous a pas échappé de temps en
temps on a eu des comparaisons
je vais vous parler de l'Allemagne pour
vous faire vibrer dans votre
enthousiasme le gouvernement et la
majorité sénatoriale un chiffre
20%. c'est le taux de pauvreté c'est le
taux de pauvreté des retraités en
Allemagne et puis aller c'est le même en
Irlande et pourtant l'âge de départ est
à 66 ans
soit 10% de plus qu'en France
60% c'est le pourcentage de pays ayant
fait machine arrière après avoir
privatisé leur régime de retraite
diminution du taux de couverture baisse
des allocations de retraite aggravation
des inégalités de gens et de revenus
c'est-à-dire croyez la comparaison
européenne c'est charge la preuve
y compris par y compris des droites
libérales excusez-moi de le dire mais
par des droites libérales
la deuxième chose c'est que tout à
l'heure on a eu la confirmation d'autres
collègues l'ont affirmé mais là on a un
moment de clarification politique
le président Retailleau a été très clair
il a dit c'est une réforme de droite
donc nous sommes en train de discuter du
réforme de droite et ça m'a fait penser
on a tous des loisirs etc j'ai pensé aux
formidable film le salaire de la peur
où il y a quatre aventuriers qui part
cupidité s'en vont à défier la nature là
on était dans les critères de pénalité
est-ce qu'on vient de vivre depuis jeudi
par le vote de la droite de la première
partie de la loi et par la défense de
rajouter deux années de plus vous êtes
en train de nous proposer de proposer
aux Français la retraite de la peur pour
les obliger à rentrer dans la
capitalisation voilà l'enjeu de cette
réforme merci Madame baraillasse
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le minis
70% des Français et plus de 90% des
salariés nous le savons sont opposés à
ce report de 62 et 64 ans de l'âge de
départ à la retraite le président de la
République avance qu'il faut que les
Français travaillent plus nous proposons
quand à nous qu'il travaille tous ce qui
permettrait d'abander les caisses des
assurances sociales avec les cotisations
nouvelles la dernière réforme
paramétrique des retraites qui fait
reculer l'âge de départ à la retraite de
60 à 62 ans évoqué par Pierre Laurent
tout à l'heure imposé par Nicolas
Sarkozy en 2010 a eu pour conséquence
selon lunédique de plonger 100 000
seigneurs dans le chômage de longue
durée entre 2010 et 2022 il ne s'agit
pas on peut le dire d'une brillante
réussite imaginons un métallurgiste ou
un salariat à la chaîne chez Renault qui
travaille souvent en 3,8 continuent à
occuper un poste de travail dans une
entreprise à 64 ans une infirmière me
disait récemment j'ai terminé ma
carrière exceptionnel par un arrêt
maladie suite à un burnout et une
période de chômage de deux ans comment
une infirmière une aide-soignante pourra
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans voire plus
repousser l'âge de départ à la retraite
c'est augmenter la période de non emploi
des seniors pour les seniors risquant de
ne pas toucher d'indemnités de chômage
durant ces années ils seront poussés
vers les minimas sociaux qui ne
permettent pas de vivre dignement est-ce
là la description d'une réforme de
gauche monsieur le ministre je ne crois
pas et si ce n'est pas l'indigent index
seniors voter dans l'article 2 de votre
loi qui risque d'inciter les entreprises
à garder les plus de 60 ans dans leurs
effectifs l'allongement des carrières va
immanquablement provoquer un surchaumage
chez les salariés les plus âgés qui
risquent plus de ne pas avoir une
carrière complète ce qui aura un impact
négatif sur leur pension future faire
basculer les dépenses de retraite sur
les indemnités de chômage est une
politique qui n'a aucun sens d'un point
de vue économique pour toutes ces
raisons bien évidemment nous demandons
la suppression de
merci
nous en avons terminé avec les
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune je vais s'il vous
plaît je vais consulter la commission
avis de la commission
bien merci monsieur le Président
j'attendais effectivement
mon tour pour donner la vie de la
commission après tous ces amendements à
répétitifs
qui font pour certains tableaux de la
valeur travail particulièrement
apocalyptique il y a encore des gens
quand même qui je pense voit les choses
différemment
Monsieur Laurent Monsieur Laurent vous
avez dit que certains rêvaient un âge de
retraite à 64 ans mais un monsieur
Laurent moi la retraite à 60 ans pour
moi c'est un cauchemar ça veut dire
qu'on n'aime pas le système par
répartition ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas
vu la société la société vieillit
Monsieur Laurent et à de moins en moins
de décence la longévité telle que la
retraite l'espérance de vie dure de plus
en plus longtemps et si vous voulez
prendre des mesures qui vont plomber le
système par répartition c'est que vous
n'aimez pas la répartition j'ai écouté
aussi monsieur Sueur monsieur Sueur qui
a fait une explication tout à fait
intéressante mais qui pense que en
travaillant effectivement plus sur la
durée et bien on pourrait peut-être
rendre les gens le plus heureux et bien
non on sait que plus la durée on
travaille sur la durée les 43 ans ça
fait les conséquences c'est qu'il y a
une diminution de la pension moyenne
calculée à de 300 euros lisez l'étude
d'impact je n'ai rien inventé donc ça
veut dire que vous n'aimez pas les
retraités que vous voulez faire des
retraités pauvres c'est la raison pour
laquelle je me tourne vers ce banc l'un
de l'émission
ce banc là de l'émission pense qu'il
faut jouer sur le niveau de l'âge légal
mais chers collègues vous avez raison
vous avez raison parce que c'est le seul
moyen dans un système pas répartition de
faire en sorte qu'on arrive à élever le
niveau des pensions faire en sorte qu'on
puisse dégager des recettes
supplémentaires et qu'on puisse faire
plus de solidarité mais vous n'aimez pas
la solidarité donc et nous nous aimons
la solidarité
et nous aimons la solidarité et nous
voudrions bien la proposer aux Français
non pas à travers des discours mais à
travers des actes ce sont les articles
suivants qui viennent pour les maires de
famille vous en parlez beaucoup nous
agissons
pour l'usure professionnelle
[Applaudissements]
je vous ai taquiné pour l'usure
professionnelle nous avons des mesures
pour la retraite progressive nous avons
des mesures en conséquence il serait
temps monsieur le Président que nous
puissions passer dans l'examen du texte
les Français attendent de nous que l'on
donne un peu plus de justice sociale à
ce texte il en manque un peu messieurs
les ministres un peu plus de justice
sociale à travers les divers
dispositions que nous souhaiterions
vivement examinés voilà vous l'avez
compris mes chers collègues la vie sera
défavorable de la part de la Commission
la ville du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
en donnant la vie du gouvernement qui
sera défavorable en réponse aux 70
amendements de suppression je ne
reprendrai pas les arguments très
synthétiques qui ont été évoqués par
Olivier dupe mais je donnerai quelques
principes qui concernent la fonction
publique les agents de la fonction
publique qui sont effectivement inclus
dans cet article 7 et en le faisant je
veux me réjouir que
dans cette chambre on puisse débattre de
la situation des agents de la fonction
publique parce que cela n'avait pas été
possible à l'Assemblée nationale et je
pense que c'était dommage de ne pas
évoquer au fond les principes qui
concernent les agents de la fonction
publique et qui sont majoritairement
dans cet article 7 d'abord je le ferai
de façon monsieur le Président très
synthétique pour aller plus vite sur
ensuite l'explication sur les différents
amendements d'abord un principe d'équité
je crois que les Français n'auraient pas
compris que les mesures des efforts qui
concernent les salariés du privé ne
soient pas demandés de façon absolument
symétrique aux agents de la fonction
publique ce sera le cas pour l'âge
d'ouverture des droits ce sera le cas
pour l'accélération de la durée de
cotisation ensuite un principe de
cohérence nous avons préservé et
conserver les caractéristiques
fondamentales du système de retraite
pour les agents de la fonction publique
sur le calcul sur les six derniers mois
calcule sur la rémunération indiciaire
des fonctionnaires ce que nous
conservons aussi c'est le principe des
catégories actives à tout point de vue
nous en conservons le principe mais nous
conservons aussi la durée de service
pour les catégories actives et Olivier
du stop la rappeler pour les catégories
actives comme pour les agences
sédentaires nous ne modifions pas l'âge
d'annulation de la décote c'est le cas
pour tous les agents de la fonction
publique et puis le troisième principe
c'est un principe de progrès
parce que en supprimant cet article 7 ce
sont des améliorations du système et des
progrès pour les fonctionnaires contre
lequel vous voteriez je veux en
mentionner de façon très rapide 3 qui
sont contenues dans ce texte d'abord la
porte habilité des droits pour les
agents publics qui sont dans les
catégories actives la situation actuelle
c'est que si vous changez de métier
quand vous êtes policier que vous
devenez par exemple douanier ou agent de
la pénitentiaire vous perdez tout le
bénéfice de vos années passées en tant
que policier ou dans la fonction
publique pénitentiaire et bien grâce à
l'article 7 nous mettons fin à cette
situation injuste plus injuste encore
votant contre l'article 7 vous viendriez
voter contre une mesure qui est la
suppression de la clause d'achèvement la
suppression de la clause d'achèvement ça
peut parfaite technique quand on le dit
comme ça mais c'est un principe qui
existe dans le système de retraite
actuel qui consiste à faire en sorte que
vous ne bénéficiez des mesures qui
concernent les catégories actives
seulement si vous terminez votre
carrière en tant que catégorie actif
c'est-à-dire dans le métier pénible
c'est-à-dire tout l'inverse de ce que
nous devons faire pour aménager les fins
de carrière et bien dans cet article 7
on le votant vous allez supprimer la
clause d'achèvement ce citerai une
troisième amélioration elle concerne les
contractuels de la fonction publique 20%
des agents publics aujourd'hui les
contractuels qui aujourd'hui font
parfois le même métier que les agents
publics qui sont intégrés actives mais
qui ne bénéficient pas des mesures de
protection qui concernent les agents des
catégories actives et bien avec
l'article 7 vous feront vous ferez en
sorte que les agents contractuels dès
lors qu'ils seront titularisés dans la
fonction publique ils verront leurs
années passées en tant que contact
actuel parfois cinq ans parfois 6 ans je
pense au plus de 100.000 agents
contractuels qui sont des
aides-soignants à l'hôpital et bien vous
ferez en sorte que ces années passées
elles contront et elles seront intégrées
dans les années de service quand ils
seront intitulés à réserves en fonction
publique voilà des avancées qui sont
inclus dans l'article 7 et autant de
bonnes raisons de donner un avis
défavorable aux amendements de
suppression de ce même article 7
du gouvernement avis défavorable de la
commission j'ai été saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public par la commission les
groupes communistes républicains citoyen
écologie le groupe socialiste et le
groupe écologiste solidarité et est
territoire je rappelle qu'il porte sur
les amendements identiques de
suppression d'explication de vote
monsieur dessus
oui merci monsieur le Président mais je
voudrais dire au rapporteur qui était
pas avec nous toute la nuit hier mais
que des amendements de solidarité on en
a posé un certain nombre qu'ils ont été
tous balayés mais oui nous aimons la
solidarité la vraie celle qui fait payer
ceux qui profitent le plus alors j'ai
déjà expliqué la la situation de blocage
démocratique dans laquelle nous étions
ce soir et vous avez commencé ce débat
hier et avant-hier par refuser tout
autre mode de financement alternatif
avec logique du travail et plus
pour les français pour les travailleurs
vous éloignez une fois de plus l'horizon
du répit avec cette réforme du décalage
de l'âge de départ à la retraite
l'horizon de la vie enfin sortie de la
course à la production pour nous
écologistes cette réforme va donc à
rebours de tous les enjeux du moment de
tous les enjeux du siècle et je reprends
les propos de d'Olivier Véran vous avez
d'autres urgences à gérer nous avons nos
urgences à gérer le défi climatique doit
être la priorité absolue qui devrait
nous mobiliser qu'il renouveliser ici
soir et weekend s'il le faut mais qui
devrait ne m'amuser beaucoup plus que
cette réforme visant à faire travailler
toujours plus
travailler plus c'est trop dur plus
c'est extraire plus c'est polluer plus
faites pour servir un modèle économique
insatiable des structures du climat
cette réforme des retraites va un
rebours de l'urgence la vraie les
rapports du corps sont beaucoup moins
inquiétants que les rapports du GIEC
beaucoup moins précis sur l'avenir aussi
beaucoup moins implacable sur notre
destin commun si la retraite par
répartition doit être renforcée c'est
parce que c'est un système de solidarité
entre les générations et si nous devons
repenser nos modes de production et
notre rapport au travail c'est aussi
dans une logique intergénérationnelle de
protection des générations futures votre
réforme participe à une logique qui
épuise l'humain et la planète en visant
des objectifs insoutenables de
croissance fini dans un monde infini non
l'inverse dans une croissance infinie
dans un monde fini c'est pourquoi nous
sommes écologistes et nous refusons
votre logique obsolète et appelons à la
suppression de cet article monsieur
Breuillet
attendez monsieur Breuillet
merci monsieur le Président j'ai bien
écouté notre rapporteur et le
gouvernement des fois d'ailleurs je je
confonds les deux parce que les propos
se ressemblent et se rapprochent et
c'est donc une réforme pour les femmes
c'est donc une réforme pour les
fonctionnaires
c'est donc une réforme pour les jeunes
c'est donc une réforme pour les ouvriers
pour les infirmières pour les
aides-soignants pour tous les métiers
pénibles mais ni les femmes ni les
fonctionnaires ni les jeunes ni les
infirmières ni les aides-soignants ni
tous ceux qui ont un métier pénible ne
la soutiennent quel ingratitude
quel ingratitude de ce peuple qui refuse
une réforme de progrès que vous nous
présentez et non seulement ils ne disent
pas seulement comme monsieur le
rapporteur avis défavorable ils disent
retrait
monsieur Retailleau
c'est un rappel au règlement monsieur le
Président à partir c'est sur la base de
l'article 38 77 amendements de
suppression
tout identique monsieur le Président je
demande cette application
donc je suis saisi par Monsieur
Retailleau président de groupe
de clôture sur les explications de vote
sur les amendements numéro 3 à 2268 en
application de l'article 38 de notre
règlement la clôture peut être proposée
lorsque au moins deux orateurs c'est le
cas d'avis contraire sont intervenus
je peux donner les paroles s'il le
souhaite à un opérateur par groupe N
pardonnez-moi un orateur par groupe et
un sénateur qui figure sur la liste donc
un groupe qui souhaite prendre la parole
monsieur Lemoine
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
après avoir entendu la litanie des
orateurs qui sont succédés pour plaider
pour plaider
parce qu'il y ait beaucoup d'arguments
similaires
qui se sont succédés je me dis que
j'aimerais bien être petite souris à la
prochaine réunion du Parti socialiste
européen parce que j'irai entendu
description de l'Apocalypse
l'exploitation de l'homme par l'homme et
ce faisant vous disqualifiez aussi des
gens comme prémunistes Costa le
président Sanchez qui ont conduit ce
type de réforme et donc eugouverne eux
ont été réélus eux ont assumé
et c'est je crois là une grande
différence avec effectivement votre
positionnement
Lionel Jospin est-il revenu sur la
réforme Balladur non
François
Hollande est-il revenu sur la réforme
verte non il a quelques petits
aménagements
reviendrez-vous sur l'article 7 s'il est
voté la réponse est non vous l'avez
d'ailleurs décrit comme une sorte
d'impôt sur la vie on sait bien que les
impôts vous les baissez jamais et donc
vous ne reviendrez jamais naturellement
là-dessus alors je vais paraphraser le
collègue Lucien Stanzione qui disait
ayez du courage et bien ayez du courage
retirer ses amendements de suppression
parce que vous ne reviendrez pas dessus
et donc pour le groupe RDPI en tout état
de cause nous votre compte parce que ces
grands écarts permanents non seulement
ça fait mal aux adducteurs mais ça fait
mal à la confiance dans la politique je
rappelle que nous sommes sur un débat de
clôture madame la Présidente donc j'ai
compris que vous étiez favorable à la
clôture en même temps voilà madame la
presse dire nous ne sommes pas surpris
par cette proposition de de notre
discussion elle parcourt quand même les
couloirs du Sénat depuis quelques heures
maintenant parmi d'ailleurs d'autres
rumeurs qui circulent qui circulent
aussi ce recours je vous le dis
sincèrement ce recours à cette procédure
est un acte de faiblesse de la part de
la droite
sénatoriale c'est une marque de
fébrilité qui vous qui parcourt vos rang
comme elle parcourt les rangs du
gouvernement je au nom d'une soi-disante
obstruction que nous en petite musique
que nous entendons depuis depuis le
début depuis le début de l'examen de ce
projet de loi vous juger d'une procédure
monsieur le Président qui est peu usité
ici au Sénat
et ce à quelques heures d'une magnifique
mobilisation dans le pays et l'annonce
d'une autre grande mobilisation
samedi prochain monsieur Lemoine nous
avons du courage
mais vous vous perdez votre sang-froid
avec ce coup de force
que nous dénonçons je le dis aussi
crûment que je le pense cette procédure
est une attaque contre la démocratie et
les droits du Parlement ce n'est pas
digne du Sénat monsieur le Président
alors parce que nous avons besoin de
maîtriser parce que nous avons besoin de
maîtriser l'ordre du jour
où l'organisation des débats dans les
prochaines heures nous demandons avec
les présidents de gauche c'est-à-dire
moi-même le président le cadener et le
président en compta la Réunion immédiate
d'une conférence des présidents
nous poursuivons monsieur le Président
Retailleau
pour indiquer que bien entendu de votre
ampoule la clôture puisque cela fait 5
jours et 5 nuits que nous avons à faire
à une obstruction je voudrais dire que
l'obstruction c'est la négation du rôle
du Parlement bien sûr
le rôle du Parlement c'est de débattre
mais de débattre pour voter on a été lu
non pas pour faire des groupes de parole
mais pour voter
l'obstruction c'est une sorte d'auto
effacement
d'autodésissement du Parlement vous
allez refuser puisque on va intrins
d'escargot de voir et de voter sur
l'ensemble du texte par exemple sur les
petites retraites par exemple sur
l'usure professionnelle par exemple sur
le handicap au travail et bien nous nous
voulons je crois que choisir de ne pas
voter c'est choisir de ne pas peser
méfiez-vous bien que l'obstruction ne
mène pas à alimenter l'anti
parlementarisme parce que les Français
vont constater qu'à force de discuter le
Parlement ne sert à rien oui je
l'affirme je l'affirme l'obstruction est
au Parlement ce qu'une désertion est un
soldat la négation même de sa mission
que le président Kader
merci monsieur le président
oserais-je dire honte à vous
honte à vous
vous êtes laissés bâillonner par le 47,1
de la Constitution et le gouvernement et
vous voulez maintenant bâillonner votre
position c'est un scandale
[Applaudissements]
l'article 38 n'a jamais été utilisé sans
faire de ma part dans cette émission
vous le faites parce que vous avez
incapable de défendre vos arguments tout
au long de ces 5 jours
nous nous sommes exprimés devant les
Français avec nos arguments avec notre
projet de société et vous vous êtes
couché
je le dis
alors mes chers collègues oui mais je
suis le président vous allez pouvoir
utiliser l'article 38 le règlement vous
en donne la possibilité
mais nous serons consultés avant cela
mais je tiens à rappeler quand même
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
du 11 juillet 2019 notez cela mes chers
amis le Conseil confirme la réserve
d'interprétation déjà formulé en 2015
selon laquelle il appartiendra au
président de séance d'appliquer cette
limitation dans le temps cette clôture
du débat ce bayonnage
cette limitation du temps de temps de
parole en veillant en respect des
exigences de clarté et de sincérité du
débat parlementaire
et bien nous ferons nous ferons les
recours auprès du conseil pour savoir si
cette sincérité a été préservée dans
cette nuit
monsieur le Président Gautard merci
merci monsieur le Président vous vous
rendez compte quand même de la
responsabilité que vous avez ce soir ici
oui la responsabilité un jour historique
de mobilisation vous choisissez vous
choisissez ce soir sur l'article 7 un
des articles plus importants l'article
qui va passer qui va donner deux ans de
plus aux Français de travail vous
décidez de bâillonner le Parlement vous
décidez de censurer le Sénat ce soir
vous imaginez la responsabilité que vous
avez par rapport à la population par
rapport à tous ceux qui nous regardent
c'est quand même lamentable je ne
comprends pas ça alors on nous dit alors
on nous dit on a
on a fait de l'obstruction mais on a eu
trois jours trois jours de débat on est
à l'article 7 c'est-à-dire qu'on est à
la moitié de ce texte où est
l'obstruction où est l'obstruction on a
eu des arguments un par un on les a
débattus où sont vos arguments on ne
vous a pas entendu une seule fois c'est
vous c'est avec votre obstruction
silencieuse qui donnait une image de la
politique désastreuse donc franchement
je ne comprends pas l'usage de cet
article l'usage de cet article 38 je
pense que vous avez encore la
possibilité de le retirer en tout cas je
me
avec mes deux autres collègues
évidemment on demande à ce que la
Conférence des Présidents puissent se
réunir parce que je pense qu'il y a
besoin c'est un moment grave c'est un
moment important je j'espère que vous
que vous que vous rendez compte de la
responsabilité que vous avez franchement
bien est-ce qu'il y a d'autres demandes
monsieur le Président Marseille
non mais merci
je suis
monsieur le Président Laurent merci
merci
je vous ai écouté depuis longtemps j'ai
écouté sur tous ces banques comme tous
mes collègues vous avez utilisé les
ressources du règlement pour faire
entendre votre opposition nous l'avons
écouté avec beaucoup de patience en
étant très conciliant en étant très
conciliant vous vouliez qu'on arrive à
l'article 7 le 7
quasiment à cette heure
bon ça a été fait et on a été et ça
continue bon le règlement il est le même
pour tout le monde il est le même pour
tout le monde et nous nous utilisons
maintenant le règlement pour faire
entendre aussi une autre voie une autre
voix une autre voix je ne vous ai pas
reproché d'utiliser le règlement pour
faire entendre vos propos votre
opposition nous utilisons maintenant le
règlement
nous utilisons
et alors et alors il est il est là il y
a même d'autres articles du règlement
qui n'ont jamais été utilisés non plus
bon vous les utilisez nous les utilisons
le règlement intérieur il a été étudié
par la par le Conseil constitutionnel il
a été approuvé chacun l'utilise c'est
normal et donc à partir de maintenant et
ben
comme on dit dans les campagnes les
mouches ont changé d'âne
d'autres demandent
l'intervention
[Applaudissements]
trois choses avant que tout procédions
votre monsieur le Président kaner
il appartient au président de séance
d'appliquer ses limitations du temps de
parole en veillant au respect des
exigences de clarté de sincérité du
débat parlementaire et je rappelle que
les révisions de notre règlement depuis
1959 ont été soumis en 2015 et 2019 au
Conseil constitutionnel comme le
président Marseille vient de le rappeler
nous avons eu sur cet article l’état 124
interventions je considère que les
exigences de clarté et de sincérité ont
été respectés par l'importance de ces
interventions
par ailleurs sur les sujets de rappel au
règlement puisque je voyais s'agiter
quelques petits livres verts l'article
38 prévoit strictement les modalités du
débat et je les ai respectés et le
rappel au règlement
constitué un détournement de procédure
mais connaissant s'est alinéa nous
allons donc maintenant procéder au vote
parce scrutin public
la clôture qui est favorable à la
clôture le manifeste enlevant la main
avis contraire
la clôture est adoptée et nous allons
maintenant engager le vote parce que
le scrutin est ouvert je
que quelqu'un demande encore à voter
le scrutin est clos
du scrutin
344 votants 340 exprimés pour
115 contre 225 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
ses amendements de suppression
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente vous avez souhaité
la réunion de la Conférence des
Présidents madame la Présidente assassin
vous avez souhaité la réunion de la
Conférence des Présidents elle est
prévue demain je vous la confirme mais
si vous souhaitez ajouter à l'ordre du
jour il faut que je reçoive par écrit et
je les intégrerai notre ordre du jour
sans aucun problème madame la Présidente
en application notre règlement
j'entends bien monsieur le Président
mais pourrais-je vous demander
solennellement une suspension de séance
parce que nous avons après l'annonce du
recours à cet article 38 nous avons
besoin de nous organiser je ne vous
demande pas une heure je vous demande 15
minutes de suspension de séance attendez
j'ai la commission m'avait fait savoir
qu'elle souhaitait aussi une suspension
de séance donc la conjonction fait le
bonheur alors madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président en effet je
demande une suspension de séance de 10
minutes pour réunir la Commission et
notre commission se réunit dans sa salle
la salle 213 je vous remercie on vous
donne un quart d'heure ce cap ça permet
de répondre à l'ensemble des demandes à
1h30
13h30 c'est pour la suite